[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
les matins du sénat la turquie a une
responsabilité historique est criminel
dans le conflit en libye les mots sont
extrêmement forts ils sont signés
emmanuel macron les passes d'armes
verbales se poursuivent entre paris et
ankara alors que la tension est à son
comble actuellement en méditerranée
l'occasion pour le sénat d'auditionner
l'ambassadeur de turquie en france
l'occasion peut-être aussi d'apaiser un
peu les choses on regarde audition on en
reparle juste après donc qui est
intervenu entre les forces navales
turques et la frégate française courbet
laquelle était en service commandé dans
le cadre d'une mission de l'otan
je rappelle qu'elle protégeait l'embargo
sur les armes au large de la libye le 10
juin et donc je rappelle que cette
mission de la frégate courbet
s'inscrivait dans l'opération autant si
guardian qui vise donc à contrôler cet
embargo
elle a voulu procéder au contrôle d'un
bâtiment sous pavillon tanzanien qui
était suspecté de transporter des armes
à destination du théâtre libyen
encore une fois malgré l'embargo or ce
bâtiment tanzanien censé transporter des
des denrées humanitaires étaient
entourés de trois bâtiments de la marine
turque qui escortait ce bâtiment de
commerce est ce que véritablement il
était nécessaire de le faire escorter de
trois bâtiments militaires
comment peut-on expliquer donc cette
présence
très militarisée des navires turcs
autour de ce bateau humanitaire
comment par ailleurs expliquer
l'utilisation abusive de l'indicatif
autant pour les navires turcs alors que
eux mêmes n'étaient pas en mission pour
l'alliance
lorsqu'ils ont été lorsqu'on leur
demandait leur identification
ils sont ceux ils se sont servis d'un
indicatif autant dont les bâtiments ne
peuvent se servir que lorsqu'ils sont en
mission au temps lorsque lors de la
prise de contact avec le cargo suspect
un avenir militaires turcs qui
l'escortaient à trois reprises illuminé
la frégate française c'est à dire qu'il
a fait usage de son radar de conduite de
tir ce qui est tout à fait inhabituelle
et constitue je le rappelle la manoeuvre
ultime avant l'ouverture du feu ce qui
entre alliés de l'otan est quand même
assez assez étrange des membres de
l'équipage se sont également postés en
casque lourd et armé sur le pont du
navire turc
et ce n'est que grâce au
professionnalisme et au sang froid des
de l'équipage du courbet qui a su réagir
donc pour faire baisser le niveau de la
violence
vous le savez vous savez que la france a
évidemment protester la ministre des
armées florence parly a eu l'occasion de
le dire la saisie immédiatement les
instances de l'otan
je crois la semaine dernière deux jours
avant l'incident du reste vous tweete y
est vous même pour vous réjouir d'un
exercice de formation entre une frégate
turque de frégate italienne et la
frégate courbet au sein du groupe
maritime permanent automne 2 alors donc
en fait la marine turque qui un jour va
vite elle a mis la frégate courbet dans
un exercice conjoint la menace d'un tir
de missile le lendemain c'est quand même
assez
assez troublant et donc vous comprenez
notre incompréhension l'émotion que ceci
a suscité bien évidemment et donc ceci
nécessite de votre part si je vous ai
accepté un certain nombre d'explications
pour nous donner évidemment la version
turque car comme vous le savez la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense du sénat essayer d'être la
plus objective possible on veut déjà
comprendre ce qui s'est passé est votre
interprétation de cet incident
s'agissant de la libye je veux rappeler
que la turquie a souscrit un certain
nombre de principes lors de la
conférence de haut sommet de berlin en
janvier dernier je rappelle que la
turquie s'était engagé à respecter
l'embargo des nations unies sur les
armes à destination de la libye ainsi
que le principe de non-ingérence dans le
conflit qui sévit dans le pays
or les événements contredisent un tout
petit peu cette prise de position
puisque il est manifeste que la turquie
cherche à disposer de nouveaux points
d'appui en libye je pense notamment aux
bases militaires de misrata et d'al
watiyah est donc là aussi vous nous
éclairer pour nous dire qu'elles sont en
vérité les ambitions de la turquie en
libye la libye est une quarantaine de
kilomètres des côtes européennes ce sont
des sujets qui nous interpellent et donc
vous nous direz si la turquie a vraiment
l'intention d'appliquer les accords de
l'accord de berlin ou bien si elle
cherche une nouvelle implantation dans
cette région du monde
vous savez que le temps a déclenché à la
demande de la france et sous l'impulsion
de son secrétaire général
une enquête afin de faire toute la
lumière sur l'incident maritime
mais d'une manière générale la france a
demandé que soit réexaminée la situation
de l'otan par rapport à ses alliés la
situation de la turquie par rapport à
ses alliés au sein de l'otan
car c'est toute l'alliance atlantique
risque d'être fragilisée
si les incidents de ceux de ce type se
multiplient alors on souhaite bien
évidemment vous vous entendre sur à la
fois ce contexte qui ne cesse du reste
de
de s'aggraver puisque les dépêche d'hier
montré des déclarations de votre mise
affaires étrangères particulièrement
agressive vis-à-vis de la france disons
que la france cherchait à installer la
russie en libye
sincèrement je peux vous dire puisque
nous conduisons un dialogue avec la
russie on les incite alors même qu' on
est en contradiction totale avec eux sur
la sphère de l'ukraine et de la crimée
je vois pas pourquoi nous aurions
intérêt à faciliter leur implantation en
libye bien évidemment la france je le
rappelle a toujours la même politique
elle parle à tout le monde donc il n'est
pas étonnant que à la fois reconnaissant
le gouvernement de tripoli
l ai eu des contacts avec marge de la
star puisque de toute façon ce sont deux
entités un qui cherche l'une et l'autre
à s'imposer en libye est ce que la
france a fait part ces différentes
initiatives c'est de tenter d'organiser
des conférences internationales des
réunions il y en a eu à paris un sous
l'égide du président macron et donc je
trouve
nous considérons je vous le dis avec
amitié et respect mais sur ma soeur nous
considérons que les attaques répétées du
miz affaires étrangères turques sont
disproportionnés par rapport aux efforts
que la france tente d'accomplir pour
amener plus tôt la paix dans une région
du monde qui en a bien besoin car vous
savez que la libye ait véritablement
maintenant le champ de manoeuvres et
d'affrontements de toutes sortes de
d'intérêt
qui malheureusement ont pour conséquence
d'alimenter les trafics de toutes sortes
en direction du sahel où la france là
aussi assument des responsabilités très
difficile très compliqué voilà pourquoi
monsieur abass ailleurs sans plus
attendre je vous laisse la parole pour
vous donner la possibilité de nous
éclairer nous dire ce que cherche la
turquie quelle est sa position quelle
interprétation que vous faites de ces
faits particulièrement graves qui se
sont produits entre deux alliés membres
de l'otan
je réaffirme bien évidemment ici que
tout ça se se situe dans un contexte qui
n'est pas positif pour une relation et
que nous reconnaissons volontiers à la
turquie le droit de faire valoir ses
intérêts dans cette partie du monde
mais la manière dont elle procède nous
paraît inamicale et c'est ce pourquoi
donc j'avais souhaité que vous puissiez
été entendues afin que nous en
débattions et je pense que mes collègues
auront l'occasion de faire préciser les
points de vue après votre intervention
sur mes soeurs vous connaissez la règle
et a explosé de l'intello minutes je
crois vous avez préparé du reste
quelques documents et puis après nous
n'aurons ce dialogue
en espérant qu'il nous permettra de
mieux nous comprendre
un est de faire en sorte que nous soyons
rassurés je l'espère sur les véritables
intentions de la turquie monsieur
l'ambassadeur vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
monsieur le sénateur merci de votre
accueil pour ce matin j'ai toujours eu
un accueil chaleureux ici sous ce toit
je dois le dire et redire monsieur le
président
vous avez évoqué certains éléments de
l'actualité
mais chut plus sensibles avons proposé
départ quand vous qualifier le contexte
un peu comme à ce qui se passe dans une
famille des tensions dans une famille
querelle dans une famille je suis très
sensible à cela le président et je me
situe dans le même état d'esprit
soyez rassurés et il nous incombe à nous
tous des gens responsables de de revoir
de voir et de revoir tout ce qui nous
préoccupe avec beaucoup de
responsabilité tout en ayant à l'esprit
le fait que ces deux pays france et
turquie entretienne des relations qui
s'étendent sur un éventail
impressionnant dans plusieurs domaines
vous l'avez sites est monsieur le
président il ya presque deux mille
entreprises françaises qui opèrent en
turquie
nous avons été en relation que la mique
politique commerciale scientifique
historique
bref il faut être conscient de cela et
il faut gérer les tensions de
circonstance à néant tout cela un esprit
je le suis moi même sur le président
depuis quelques semaines en france aussi
la l'actualité la presse est préoccupé
par ce qui se passe en libye en syrie ce
qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé en
méditerranée entre les et les éléments
maritime france-turquie courbet et au le
cheese tout cela je vais te dis je vais
essayer de préparer quelque chose qui
tienne compte de ce qui préoccupe
l'opinion publique française à ce que je
puis je peux observer mais sa courbe les
éléments d'appréciation que vous avez eu
l'amabilité de partager avec nous ce
matin monsieur le président je voyais
que beaucoup de questions tourner autour
de savoir que fait la turquie en libye
parce que ça remonte à cela il d'un jeu
peut l'exposer de la manière suivante
monsieur le président nous connaissons
la situation dans le terrain depuis 2011
le lien presque pas d'autorité centrale
tout est éparpillé le pays est dans une
guerre à la fois un terme mais des
imbrications externe aussi qui font que
il ya une situation douloureuse et en
il ya eu un accord politique au maroc
mme chirac
nous l'avons tous endossé turquie france
des nations unies tous les pays
concernés qu'au prix mais en dépit de
cela il y a eu des tensions internes
cette fois ci en libye on le sait une
personnalité qui se
nomme comme général je parle de monsieur
after et il a essayé de tout faire pour
déconnecter cet accord politique de son
contexte nous le savons tous et il a
s'est lancé dans une attaque militaire
qui dont le tournant est thomas de mad
avril 2019 et il n'ya accord d'autres
mots de cela si on ne faisait rien ben
tripoli allait tomber dans les mains
d'un général haftar le staff tard est-ce
que nous sommes prêts à cela
d'un côté nous soutenons un gouvernement
nous légitimons nous en doutons faisons
tout nous reconnaissons cocktails comme
autorité politique en libye et en même
temps nous restons dans l'expectative
alors qu'il est attaqué de partout ce
qui est ce que la présence turque en
libye c'est bien cela
monsieur le président d'ailleurs la
turquie n'était pas le seul pays à être
invité par le gouvernement légitime
à tripoli l'otan a été invité et quatre
autres pays et de la france ont été
invités pour mettre la main là dessus
pour faire quelque chose pour aider le
gouvernement de sa rage là il convient
de ne pas être un déballage part d'une
manière générale donc soit soit nous
assumons nos responsabilités au nous
nous soutenons l'avions évoqué avec une
sauce inter aussi à aux autres missions
en libye ce gr il faut qu'on tranche
soit on dit à ce gouvernement central
écoutez nous on vous soutient son ami
mais écoutez vous vous allez vous allez
prendre vos dispositions
vous même la turquie a répondu par
l'affirmatif pour soutenir ce
gouvernement légitime que nous avons
reconnu nous tous la communauté
internationale donc la turquie se situe
dans la stricte légalité elle a répondu
à une
invitation qui émanait de de
gouvernement légitime à tripoli et
monsieur le président je me permet de
partager avec vous et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
à qui je dois beaucoup aussi puisque
nous échangeons souvent avec avec avec
eux un peu sur tous les sujets je peux
vous dire que s'il n'y avait pas cette
intervention turc
aujourd'hui il n'y aurait pas de
gouvernement légitime à tripoli notre
appréciation de la chose est bien cela
donc est ce qu'on est prêt à cela
est ce qu'on peut tolérer cela ça c'est
une autre appréciation que le
gouvernement légitime peut se dire mais
où le soutenaient ok d'accord mais que
vaut ce gouvernement pas grand chose
pas grand chose il veut ce gouvernement
central et nous le comprenons ce
gouvernement central souhaite que les
forces de monsieur haftar se retire à
l'époque aux frontières à la ligne de
démarcation de 2015 2015 ou cet accord
de cheratte au maroc a été signé et je
sais pas s'il ya eu ce que vous faire
passer une carte de libye sur sur
l'écran comme ça je peux essayer de oui
celui-là vous je n'ai pas de carte
précise là dessus mais si ma mémoire ne
me trahit pas cette ligne de démarcation
passerait et quelque part alès ii de
cécité et dans le plus plus dans le sud
geoffroy qui sont encore aujourd'hui
contrôlée par par les éléments d'un star
dont ils demandent aussi le retrait des
forces d'un retard de 6 tey et 2 et de
jeux fra et aussi ils soutiennent ils
demandent qu'on établisse une véritable
feuille de route politique qu'on puisse
mettre en oeuvre et aussi ils sont
étouffées depuis 2011 monsieur le
président il n'y a presque pas grand
chose dans le pays le pays s'appauvrit
ils peuvent pas vendre de pétrole on le
sait ne rapplique un embargo
il empêche il empêche que la société
nationale libyenne puisse exporter de
pétrole vers l'étranger pour subvenir
aux besoins de la population
donc ce sont quand même des des demandes
eu des demandes légitimes pour un
gouvernement que nous avons tous reconnu
maintenant monsieur le président je
reviendrai je voudrais revenir à ce qui
est peut-être plus sensible pour pour
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
aussi cet incident entre les navires
français et turcs
je vais essayer de dresser une liste de
séquences que vous l'avez sur l'écran
les marins le savent
de surcroît les forçats mais le savent
très bien
dans les pratiques maritimes monsieur le
président on le questionne pas un navire
trois fois dans la même journée
en 24 heures le navire tueur a été
interrogé à quatre reprises c'est du
jamais vu
il l'a j'invite votre compréhension
c'est comme si on douter des bonnes
intentions de 2,2 de la partie turque en
la matière que se passe-t-il dans un
premier temps dans un premier temps un
navire grec qui opère qui opèrent dans
le cadre de l'opération
irini vous n'avez ici
hss pète ça et à 13h43 zoulou il faut
mettre trois heures de plus pour voir
leur françaises dans le cadre de
l'ironie ce navire turc est interrogé
c'est pas fini quelques heures plus tard
le navire italien i ts carabine riz il
interroge pour le même objectif et ça se
passe très bien
ni dans le premier cas ni dans le cas
suivant pas de problème tout se déroule
normalement et c'est pas fini on
interroge le deuxième c'est dans le
cadre de l'otan deuxième opération on
interroge le même navire en moins de 24
heures la troisième fois à 16h58 et avec
des pratiques qui ne sont pas
habituelles dans dans la vie maritime
on observe une vitesse extrêmement élevé
à 20 noeuds grand-angle de gouvernail et
de billard de la pro de tcg aux
richesses
est ce que on peut oui voilà jour
j'attire votre attention monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sur cette carte
ces documents ces documents ont été
circulaire l'otan par notre délégation
permanente donc madame madame la
représentante
française a dû sûrement suivre et faire
remonter l'information
voyez courbet tout au début au début à
une vitesse de 15 noeuds ce navire
suisse est tracé rouge continue continue
il passe entre les deux navires après il
contourne le coq au vin qui est un autre
et il fait ce que les chauffeurs
qualifie moi je peux pas le jeu ne peut
pas trouver mieux pour m'exprimer là
dessus quand en circulation on vous fait
un que de poissons vous n'êtes vous êtes
plutôt énervé et ça risque de provoquer
un incident monsieur le président ce que
fait courber c'est comme un queue de
poisson une manoeuvre très rapide il se
positionne devant au round 6 ortschitt
alors que vers l'iss le navire turc
1 il n'éclaire pas courber qu'il a
ravitaillé le même jour qu'est ce qu'il
fait il a seulement désigné courbet pour
surveiller les malheurs parce que ils ne
savent pas ce qui se passe comme il voit
courbet manoeuvrait de manière à une
vitesse accélérée
il faut qu'il observe il tourne la
caméra dans leur système
le radar et le caméras sont incorporés
et il change d'orientation en même temps
mais il ya toujours pas d'illumination
il n'active pas le radar de contrôle de
tir
ça nous avons remis re l'otan vous
verrez dans la présentation suivante
mesdames et monsieur le sénateur je vous
invite s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît à
observer cela de près parce que
le tout est une étude d'appréciation à
bach à partir des données techniques
d'un côté vous avez les éléments qui
justifient la désignation du côté gauche
à droite vous avez l'illumination
dans le cas de l'illumination
qu'est ce qu'on a dans le cas de
désignation dans l'écran comme on vient
de voir désignation affiché sur l'écran
est toujours sur l'écran seulement la
date et l'heure sont sur l'écran comme
vous voyez pas de données concernant la
distance
je crois que l'élément crucial c'est
cela quand vous êtes en désignation il
n'y a pas de distance entre l'objet
observé et vous même sur votre écran ça
ces désignations quand il s'agit de
l'illumination
parce que pour pouvoir tirer vous devez
avoir la distance entre on veut pas
tirer le mot jacking ou la
l'illumination est affiché quand vous
vous voulez illuminé ok c'est un quine
qui s'affiche et il y a dans l'écran un
petit cadran milieu qui vous aurions
pour viser ça nous l'avons pas sur
l'écran de navires tueur nous les avons
communiqué à l'otan monsieur le
président la date
dans le cas d'élimination on doit voir
la date l'heure et la distance qui est
obligatoire pour se lancer dans une
opération de tir tout cela font défaut
ça n'existe pas c'est cela qu'on a
désignation s'était ouvert pour
contrôler par tout le monde on continue
on revient à la main d'un troisième
élément dans le texte que je voulais
les évoquer oui est-ce que vous pouvez
remettre cette comparaison désignation
illuminations oui oui et petit carré au
milieu oui je venais de le dire pardon
dans ce dans ce contexte là on avait
deux versions différentes
alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait le
secrétaire général de l'otan monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
il a ordonné une investigation là-dessus
qui vient d'être fait
d'après les informations que j'ai eu ça
n'est pas concluante
compte tenu de 2,2 de la réclamation de
nos amis français
ils ont remonté l'information au sein de
l'enceinte l'otan mais semble-t-il
semble-t-il les experts de l'otan
n'arrive pas à la même conclusion et
vous l'avez peut-être l'information
monsieur le président je les jeux les
oeillères nous semble-t-il courbet se
retire de cette opération de l'otan vous
avez peut-être l'information en attente
en mai et là je pense que en toute
amitié ce que je peux partager et portez
à votre aimable attention il ya une
présentation à des versants pas tout à
fait technique au début mais on arrive à
une conclusion qui n'est pas du tout
celle qui est présentée au départ qu'est
ce que je veux dire par là et le
vos habitudes mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ils n'ont pas compris une
chose il y à une cellule de
communication entre les forces armées
turques et françaises entre nos états
majeurs
noam et français n'ont pas daigné passer
par cela
tout ce que j'ai essayé humblement de
partager avec vous sur ce sur cet écran
il se contente de l'observer le
commandant de deux courbes et il ne il
ne veut pas passer en communication avec
avec le commandant doris il ne passe pas
par les instances nationales
il remonte l'information à l'otan sans
avoir
recours à des vérifications préalables
nôtre est un majeur ne l'a pas compris
et nous l'avons nous n'avons évoqué
notre attaché militaire l'a évoqué
auprès de ses interlocuteurs
institutionnels à paris quand il a eu
l'opportunité est l'occasion d'échanger
avec eux il croit que sont bien entendu
il n'y a pas eu de problème à ce niveau
là et que de part et d'autre on avait
compris qu'il y avait besoin de
communiquer davantage la faire courber
monsieur le président de notre point de
vue ça n'est pas ça n'est pas un acte
inamical de surcroît ça n'est pas
hostile et nous n'avons pas compris
pourquoi ça a pris cette tournure et que
qu'on a qu'on a pu essayer de sortir
surtout dans les médias la chose de son
contexte et les experts de l'otan
n'arrive pas à conclure à dessus il
n'arrive pas à dire ah tiens oui c'est
bien de cette manière là qu'ils faudrait
qu'il faudrait la voir il y a le seul
autre président et pour ce qui concerne
les
les éléments tueur sur le navire qui
sont qui serait armé mais dans tout
navire c'est comme ça mais leurs fusils
ne sont pas orientés
il ya d'ailleurs il ya d'ailleurs une
photo prise par nos amis français à la
mer à la matière voilà cette photo-là de
la virtual tennis savez on arrive à
détecter les canons sont orientés vers
le ciel mais si vous êtes si vous pensez
que vous avez vous avez affaire à un
objet considéré comme comme common comme
ennemis mais vous vous vous orientez
votre pistolet votre arme vers celui-ci
papa dans l'air et cette photo elle est
prise par nos amis français
les mitrailleuses ne sont pas pointés
vers fès courbet mais vers le ciel le
caméra électro optique en mode de
désignation sans activer le radar de
contrôle de tir et sans illuminé vous
voyez quand on illumine les radars ne
sont pas observées comme ça c'est pas
cette présentation qu'on aurait dû
rationner robin monsieur le président
peut-être que je me suis attardé trop là
dessus sur sur cette séquence
mais je crois que ça vaut la peine et
pour bien comprendre les choses
pour bien les apprécier il faut que nous
puissions y consacrait le temps le temps
nécessaire monsieur le président là on
peut passer en revue les photos qui
indique que le ravitaillement alors le
notre ami à l'appareil voilà voilà
c'est beau quand même ces scènes là non
mais ce que tu peux passer en arrière
s'il te plaît tu as perdu le fil
bon alors il ya eu un problème technique
bon il viendra peut-être même si on
faisait cependant que le problème
technique est réglée je me permets de
revenir parce que je suis aussi
l'interprétation de la marine française
donc ça permet justement d'entretien le
débat tout d'abord la question de fond
que tout le monde se pose c'est si la
cargaison est inoffensive pourquoi trois
bâtiments de guerre l'entourent ce
navire tanzanien qu'est ce qu'il y avait
dans le navire tanzanie à monsieur
l'ambassadeur
ce que j'ai comme informations ce sont
de l'aide humanitaire mais ce qui
justifie c'était juste elle était bien
jouer à des jeux gamers là dessus les
éléments de réponse dans mes propos
introductif monsieur le président le
navire est interrogé trois fois en moins
de 24 heures
de surcroît il considère cela comme une
anomalie et ils font appel aux forces
georges barret team pour ne pas avoir
des difficultés du jeu c'est de quelle
nature
parce que le fait que le même navire
grec le matin 3h 43 l'interrogent
après ça passe y'a pas de problème est
il trop quatre heures plus tard c'est un
navire de l'otan qui l'interrogent
carabine carabine rit ça passe et après
c'est le tour de courbet tt rs qu'on a
un doute non pardon c'est peut-être
parce qu'on a un doute sur ce qui à
droite pourquoi alors le monsieur le
président pourquoi le premier à lâcher
alors pas le premier ne devait pas
lâcher je suis pas le responsable à
marino la version viol j'ai c'est que le
bateau français tentent de s'approcher
du cargo dans un avenir pour prendre un
certain nombre de photos parce qu'il ya
un doute manifestement et encore une
fois le doute né du fait que
un navire humanitaire entouré de trois
frégates assez lourdement armés sur sa
fausse question enfin je suppose si
c'est vrai que fut capitaine de vaisseau
maintenant mais uniquement de réserve
monsieur le président je ne suis pas
expert mais bon je encore une fois les
oeufs les opérations l'a10 à contrôler
un embargo
il faut bien reprendre des choses depuis
débat on contrôle un embargo non la
turquie et solidaire depuis les accords
de berlin 10 ans il faut pas alimenter
d'armes supplémentaires les forces en
présence donc là on voit un bateau dont
on nous dit qu'il est chargé de matières
humanitaire et puis il est entouré de
trois navires de guerre turcs assez
lourdement armés donc c'est ça qui a dû
poser problème j'imagine est bon vous a
expliqué très bien la manoeuvre la
marine nationale conteste le fait que le
courbet est arrivé à grande vitesse je
pense qu'ils ont acquis toujours d'après
ce qui nous est dit de pas ce qui m'a
été dit que le courbet accélère
justement pour éviter la collision au
moment où on voit que les opérations se
tendent un peu mais il n'y a pas eu de
volonté de
ni d'aucune pression ni quoi que ce soit
sont des manoeuvres que nous ne fassions
il ya peu d'experts autour de cette âme
mais il y avait manifestement la volonté
d'en savoir un peu plus et vous le dites
vous même
il ya trois contrôles généralement c'est
très rare c'est très rare vad
si on demande à trois ou quatre reprises
et c'est qu'il ya un doute oui à un
doute qui peut et qui peut naître je
pense que c'est surtout ça tant qu'elle
illuminations de la marine nationale
continue à dire et à maintenir que le
radar de conduite de tir a été allumé à
trois reprises un à trois reprises une
fois trente secondes une fois 40
secondes une fois trente secondes sur
notre frégate
ni vous ni moi n'y étions mais enfin je
comprenais que on se rapporte à la
version que nous donne la marine
nationale
alors effectivement qu'ils aient eu
tracking ou pas tracking et enfin le
fait d'avoir allumé le radar de conduite
de tir est une manoeuvre qui dans toutes
les marines nationales est considérée
comme inamicale
d'accord il ya meilleure manière de se
saluer en mer que d'allumer son radar de
conduite de tir sur le bateau d'en face
une interprétation que j'en fais
monsieur l'ambassadeur nom est justement
il faut il vendre il faut qu'on échange
là dessus en toute franchise mais de
monsieur le président vous conviendrez
avec moi que c'est quand même une
anomalie qu'on contrôle un navire trois
fois en moins de 24 noms mais non c'est
une anomalie mais non et si c'est contre
l'embargo 1 à dire dont on nous dit
qu'il est chargé
de deux produits humanitaires bon
entouré comme dans une armada l'armada
dont on parle monsieur le président il
ils sont là c'est trop navire turc
justement dans le cadre de cette
opération de l'otan peut pour apporter
leur soutien à cette opération de l'otan
ils sont pas là par hasard
et comme on à la tendance de le dire ils
sont pas partis des d'abord quelconque
de turquie pour accompagner accompagner
ce navire check in ils sont là dans le
cadre de cette opération de l'otan qui a
pour but contrôler veut l'embargo pour
la libye la marine nationale française
dans le savoir je suis sur ces trois
frégates turques
ils sont là oui mais dans le cadre de
cette opération de l'otan en soutien
savez que dans une opération il y a
plusieurs plusieurs niveaux il ya des
éléments qui sont en première ligne et
dans celle ci
c'est la frégate française il ya
d'autres qui sont qui son soutien c'est
d'ailleurs dans cet esprit monsieur le
président je vous remercie de 2,2 me
citer dans le contexte
j'avais partagé sa part tweet c'est pour
cela qu'ils ont d'ailleurs ravitailler
courbet
dans l'est dans les mêmes lieux donc
leur présence sur place n'a pas d'autres
buts ac davie ratures sur pas parti pour
accompagner le navire sisskin qui qui
qui a pour but de transmettre de
matériel humanitaire en libye
ce qu'on veut dire simplement c'est que
si dans le cas d'une inspection d'un
embargo pas le plus simple dans ce cas
là s'il ya un doute si à trois ou quatre
interrogations successives donc c'est
qu'il ya un doute le plus simple de bon
sens c'est de lever le doute et
d'autoriser une inspection c'est très
facile d'un bateau à l'autre on peut
aller inspecter ce qui est dedans mais
s'est passé personne ne l'a évoqué par
exemple le le capitaine de de courbet ou
autre il y a eu cet incident dont
j'essaie et d'étayer avec vous je cours
je considère que c'est tout à fait
technique mais sainté reese n'a pas il
n'a pas voulu prendre contact avec son
homologue turc du tout il a fait et il a
fait ce mouvement dangereux quand même
ce que de poissons et puis cette année
il en est allé et nos autorités n'ont
pas été contactés monsieur le président
on a remonté l'information à l'automne
tout de suite quand même il est il est
difficile d'avancer dans des conditions
je confirme hélas nous nous sommes enfin
on va pas rester toute la matinée sur
cette affaire mais les navires turcs eux
n'étaient pas en mission otan ça c'est
absolument certain
on l'a depuis le on a ces renseignements
depuis le commandement de l'otan il
n'était pas en mission otan vous n'avez
pas le droit de servir du code
d'identification autant ça s'est inséré
informations que j'ai là aussi il faut
il faut que
je voulais je les donne la réflexion de
la commission mais les trois navires en
question ne faisait pas partie de la
mission de contrôle de l'embargo
monsieur le président alors je les jours
cela comme élément de réflexion si ils
ne sont pas dans le cadre d'une mission
de l'otan comment se fait-il que le même
jour le navire turc ravitaille le navire
français courbet ça se passe pas par
hasard et des navires les na'vi
s'agissait d'une autre opération va
écouter c'est une opération en anglais
on appelle à chercher sa porte qui sont
dans le cadre d'une mission continue de
protection maritime dans le cadre de
l'otan gauvin que china et orgasme
ils sont là dans le cadre d'une mission
de l'otan c'est pour cette raison là qu
il ravitaille courbet monsieur le
président parce que on y versera encore
une fois le les miquettes toute la
matinée a fait les la version que nous
avons est formel sur ce plan les navires
turcs qui entourent le bâtiment de
soignants n'appartiennent pas à
l'instant où l'on parle là à 3h43 zoulou
n'appartiennent pas à la mission de
contrôle de l'embargo mais vous avez
évoqué d'autres d'autres éléments
monsieur le président nos amis français
la barre in les forces armées mystères
de la défense ont communiqué ses
informations à l'otan aussi l'otan à
établir à mort et si j'ai bien compris
ce rapport n'est pas concluant monsieur
le président je crois que il faut il
faut en tenir compte et où s'il
s'agissant des embargos sur président
les tur vos amis turcs ne comprennent
pas pourquoi en europe
de surcroît en france on s'intéresse
seulement seulement à un contrôle d'un
embargo maritime alors que nous avons
tous vous comme moi la presse française
en fait état juif et j'ai fait un
recueil je vous le remettrait en partant
alors que l'embargo et violée sur une
base quotidienne
du côté de la frontière égyptienne
l'embargo est violée aussi par la voie
aérienne
il y a chaque jour chaque jour des vols
à partir de deux émirs arabes unis de
céret ou autre à destination de de libye
cet embargo mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et violer quotidiennement par
voie aérienne et terrestre
pourquoi on ne pose pas des questions
là-dessus
pourquoi on est si indulgent là dessus
j'ai fait des registres vraiment à des
bases à 30 km de de tokyo
dans notre ville à l'est de libye chaque
jour il y a des cargaisons qui arrivent
par avion
financé par émirats arabes unis je crois
que pour mon bien être conséquent avec
nous même monsieur le président il faut
remonter ça aussi il faut il faut le
condamner aussi et il faut prendre des
dispositions nécessaires parce que la
décision des nations unies concernant
l'embargo
elle ne fait pas elle n'opère pas par
sélection elle ne dit pas qu'on doit
opérer la voie maritime est pas à la
voie aérienne ni ming et reste mais nous
nous avons cette impression c'est plutôt
une constatation que que qu'on procède
par sélection et que et que ça revient à
fortifier rang vous renforcez soutenir
mme savard à l'est alors là j'ai voulu
vraiment partager cela avec vous
monsieur le président vous avez évoqué
beaucoup de beaucoup d'autres éléments
les escales 200 forages dans l'est
méditerranéen peut-être que peut-être
que avec votre permission
est ce qu'on arrive à revenir à l'écran
est ce que le problème technique est
surmontée j'aurais pu dire quelques mots
pour la méditerranée orientale et
laisser la parole comme nous le
souhaitons tous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs mais
apparemment le problème technique n'est
pas surmontée
je me permets de excusez moi je n'ai pas
d'autre choix
ça sera sûrement très peu de tout à
l'heure mais pour l'âme et à la
méditerranée orientale monsieur le
président notre position a été clair et
net il y à deux versants pour nous qui
sont capitales d'un côté et la carte
malheureusement j'arrive pas à le
montrer
il y a d'un côté notre souhait de 2,2 de
défendre nos droits en tant que turc
dans la méditerranée et c'est dans la
zone économique exclusive qui est
communiqué aux nations unies et d'un
autre côté en tant que pays garants de
la république de chypre
d'une manière générale tels que ça a été
institué en 1960
aussi nous sommes soucieux de la
protection des droits des chypriotes
turcs qui sont pas prises en
considération malheureusement par le
gouvernement reconnue entre guillemets
du sud
alors si on suivait monsieur le
président je crois que dans les
relations internationales
il doit y avoir un sens de justice même
relative un sens de justice même
relative
nous ne devons pas le perdre de vue
si on prenait comme référence les
souhaits de nos amis et grecs et
chypriotes craig grecque
la turquie qui a une cote de plus de
1800 km dans la méditerranée mais sera
condamnée dans la méditerranée ça c'est
inadmissible et inacceptable et ça sera
jamais accepté nos amis grecs ne le
comprennent pas mais je crois que le
temps viendront pour qu'ils ne
comprennent ce que vous peut pas on peut
pas continuer de cette manière là je
disais je parlais de deux éléments
techniques
malheureusement l'écran n'est pas
affichée sur l'écran et deux facteurs
pour établir l'élément central qui est
l'équité et que nous mettons en avant
dans ce contexte un longueur côtière
comparative un pays avec le littoral le
plus long devrait recevoir plus de jeux
réduction barretines dans la
méditerranée ce que c'est bien cela que
nos amis grecs ne comprennent pas ce qui
complique les choses la présence des
îles des îles fausse l'équité c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est la tradition de
droit maritime
elle ne devrait pas se voir attribuer de
zone de juridiction maritime structures
sont sûres nous avons donc défini nos
frontières maritimes en méditerranée
orientale
sur la base de sept principes et je suis
navré ça ne marche pas j'avais des
choses à vous montrer sur succion sur
l'écran messi62 amis grecs eux sont
prêts à négocier à discuter sur ces
bases de tora internationale à ce que on
ne cesse de nous rappeler le droit des
traités le droit commun sont égaux b
les droits de la mer ses droits de
dorian droit c'est pas mais l'élément
décisif chose mais il ya des conventions
internationales louis 11 mai dans ce qui
est le droit de la mer monsieur le
président il est basé sur l'équité dont
j'essaie de partager avec vous les
principes bien nous avaient craint
qu'ils disent non non on n'était pas
content de cela et comme par hasard il
est encore une semaine de cela ils ont
signé un traité un accord avec la
l'italie qui est basée sur les thèses
que nous défendons exactement je vous
invite à étudier s'il vous plaît
l'accord barretines qu'à passer nos amis
qu on passait nos amis grecs avec nos
amis italiens
c'est exactement quasiment les thèses
que nous mettons en avant pour trouver
une solution durable au contentieux qui
nous oppose avec avec la grèce monsieur
le président vous avez évoqué à raison
la tension et puis les déclarations
appelant à un moratoire de parts de
voilà voilà
hélas
voyez vous voyez je disais qu'il y avait
deux éléments je veux pas m'attarder
davantage là dessus puisque j'ai trop
près votre temps précieux
il faut qu'on vous laisse de temps pour
les questions voilà le grand rouge en
dessous à gauche c'est la zone
économique exclusive de la turquie et à
droite pour les forages
c'est important en verte j'avais partagé
une carte avec vous je crois monsieur le
sénateur notice qui est on vous disait
que je ne voudrais pas faire la
distinction
j'ai réussi à laver repasser en verte
pour que ce soit plus visible c'est du
côté droit comme la question elle n'est
pas résolue monsieur le président la
question chypriote elle n'est pas
résolue
c'est parce qu'elle n'est pas résolu
tout le monde dans l'île peut prétendre
et vouloir faire valoir ses droits
autour de ligne c'est de ce principe que
sa part et dans cet espace verte
le gouvernement chypriote turc a accordé
le droit d'aider des licences doit de
recherche pour des forages comme nos
amis grecs dans le sud font avec
d'autres avec avec eni avec total avec
exxonmobil et c'est donc là c'est
tellement je n'ai partageait avec
certains d'entre vous lors de nos
entretiens président nous ne voulons pas
arrêter le temps nous voulons pas
condamner les chypriotes grecs et turcs
à une impossibilité
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
puisque nous n'avons pas une solution
pacifique
aujourd'hui pour la question chypriote
alors pour avancer dans le domaine du
forage
les chypriotes grecs et turcs peuvent se
mettre d'accord sur les modalités
d'opération de forage
c'est dire que qu'il mette un comité
c'est le sens de la proposition du
gouvernement une créature de 13 juillet
2019 qu'il mette un comité en somme
paritaire qu'ils décident les modalités
de faux
rage ensemble qu'ils décident les
modalités de partage des revenus
ensemble nous ne voulons pas autre chose
qu'on continue de négocier pour trouver
une solution à la question j'ai pris là
y'a pas de problème mais pour les
sources énergétiques
on peut procéder de cette manière là je
crois que la france en tant que pays
membre des nations unies peut contribuer
considérablement dans cette perspective
vous voyez monsieur le président cette
carte je vous invite à la halle à
consulter à égale distance et qui
distance entre le continent turcs et
grecs
si si si si mais si on prenait il ya
vous prenez une île qui est à 20 km de
la turquie et 570 km de la grèce et on
veut que ça a le même effet d'un point
de vue de droit maritime
c'est pour cela qu'on a inventé la
notion d'équité nous seuls présidents
l'équité alors si on emprunte cette
logique qui à mon sens est biaisé à une
île de 10 kilomètres carrés eh ben on
reconnaîtrait à deux kilomètres des
côtes turques seulement 2 km et 570 km
de la grèce devait générer une zone
économique zone de juridiction marais
type de 48 kilomètres carrés mais c'est
une aberration
ce présent c'est une aberration je ne
mâche pas mes mots unis qui se situe à 2
km de nos côtes
dès que le des kilomètres carrés devait
générer un effet de juridiction maritime
de quarante mille kilomètres carrés
mais c'est pas possible on peut pas
vivre ah ben non c'est vrai c'est le nom
c'est le droit de la mer
je sais pas le droit de la mer il ya des
exceptions qui confirment la règle entre
le canada et la france entre l'italie et
la grèce
il ya des exemples je peux vous faire un
jour une présentation complète la dre
rien que l'exemple français on a une
zone économique exclusive très important
notamment parce qu'on a un certain
nombre d'illégaux tour de saisine l'on
bénéficie a exhorté que monsieur le
président avec toute l'amitié que je
vous dois et à mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je sais vous le savez que la france se
pose au canada et évoque cette même
principe d'équité à saint pierre et
miquelon exactement la même thèse ce qui
est légitime pour la france pourquoi
elle ne serait pas pour nous en tout un
métier je pose la question
la france soutient la même thèse et elle
s'oppose à la politique canadienne
s'agissant de saint pierre et miquelon
se basant sur ce même principe
s'il vous plaît il faut qu'on décide au
niveau on peut pas dire tiens ça va dans
un contexte ça ne va pas dans l'autre
sommes d'accord mais il faut que ça soit
valable apporte au jeu monsieur le
président donc là vous avez je voulais
juste et rapidement faire enfin faire
référence à ses déclarations le
président je voudrais
toute amitié partagé une chose avec vous
je crois que les turcs et les français
ils doivent se parler d'abord avant de
communiquer par médias interposés vous
voyez ce que je veux dire monsieur le
président en toute amitié
ce que certaines déclarations émanant de
la france nous a attristée aussi
vraiment la responsabilité historique
est criminel
un jeu dangereux je ne vais pas aller au
delà
mais ce que nous faisons en libye c'est
clair quand certains me soutient 1
m autrefois terroristes quand même
haftar c'est pas c'est pas le la
personne la plus légitime qu'on puisse
trouver en libye quand on le soutient on
ne joue pas un jeu dangereux
et quand on se soutient le gouvernement
légitime alors la turquie joue un jeu
dangereux
c'est quand même un tort à votre ami et
allié turc non vous ne pensez pas à jeu
en toute honnêteté et amitié jeu je
soumets cela à votre approbation
alors quand on soutient le gouvernement
légitime nous on joue un jeu dangereux
et quand certains pays l'egypte les
émirats arabes unis et d'autres
soutiennent after arrêt ils sont dans la
légimité ne joue pas dangereux c'est
quand même biais et non moi ça me
chagrine vraiment alors aussi monsieur
le président vous cette maison est très
sensible à des atrocités
il faut les combattre il faut les
dénoncer et publiquement la presse
française en effet timidement est un
les forces de retard quand ils sont
retirés de tarragona récemment qu'elle
atrocités elles ont commises s'il vous
plaît moi j'aimerais bien voir mes amis
français à parler la presse française
inverse et a cédé fosses communes
cole a découvert sur place after ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas un ange
vous me direz dans les circonstances
actuelles en libye il est difficile de
faire la part des choses mais si oui
est-ce que vous pouvez juste avant qu'on
en vienne aux questions nous donner un
élément de réponse sur les milices les
milices turc
on a près de six mille miliciens auprès
du gouvernement d'entente nationale
notamment la milice sa date indiquée
d'inspiration turcs et qui est de le
gouvernement que qu'est ce qu'ils font
là c'est ces miliciens ces groupes
étrangers qui transforme les la libye en
terreau idéal pour le terrorisme qui est
pourquoi ils sont là les ministres en
libye qui a de tout tout par monsieur le
président il ya des soudanais il ya des
tchadiens
oui il y a décidé des syriens qui sont
transportés par par les voix qui vous
sont commis juste parce que la turquie
peut s que la turquie est obligé l2 des
sortes et des des mercenaires comme ça
pour le président nous l'avons pas
n'avons pas nier la turquie compte tenu
de l'accord que nous avons passé avec le
gouvernement soutient le gouvernement
d'un point de vue
militaire consistant en conseil
militaire technique là il ne le nie pas
et 6,6 sur la composition exacte des
forces de gouvernement national de
gouvernement légitime de monsieur salage
c'est un problème interne à l'ue nos
forces sont sur place pour les
conseiller d'un point de vue militaire
mais a passé en revue la composition de
leurs troupes s'il ya des syriens s'il
ya des tchadiens c'est à d'autres ça
c'est un autre problème
mais si on doit parler en libye des
milices des ministres je crois que la
turquie est le tout dernier gp à qui on
devait poser la question est ce que est
ce que les soudanais sont là est-ce que
les éléments de wagner sont là est-ce
que les tchadiens sont là on le sait oui
et j'ai eu un collègue venait de me le
dire encore il ya trois jours de cela on
a dû à la frontière tchado libyenne on a
dû arrêter 150-200 plus de 150
mercenaires qui essayait de gagner le
théâtre libyen alors là si on veut que
tout cela qu'on mette une fin à tout
cela eh ben il faut il faut agir encore
davantage et il faut soutenir la
légitimité internationale que nous avons
signés monsieur le président très bien
monsieur basser va passer aux questions
si vous voulez bien pour avancer un peu
je crois qu'on en visio sylvie goy
chavent est ce qu'elle est là sylvie le
oui oui je suis là merci beaucoup en
visioconférence merci infiniment
monsieur l'ambassadeur le ministre turc
des affaires étrangères a récemment
critiqué emmanuel macron pour ses
récents commentaires sur le soutien de
la turquie au gouvernement libyen
affirmant que la france entendait
rétablir l'ancien ordre colonial en
libye alors en libye
la turquie est en rupture assez nette
avec ses alliances traditionnelles ne
cherche-t-elle pas à flatter le
nationalisme d'une partie de l'opinion
publique turque dans une période
économique qui s'annonce comme on le
sait tous très très tourmentée et avec
le risque à court terme d'être chassé du
nord de la syrie je vous remercie
monsieur l'ambassadeur
merci s'ils vivent maintenant jean marie
bockel
merci monsieur le président monsieur
l'ambassadeur
c'est bravo pour votre plaidoyer
c'était bien essayé mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile en ce moment d'être
c'est mon cas amis de la turquie parce
que on a vraiment le sentiment que
malgré les vos efforts la la comment
dirais-je l'impérialisme du président
turc eux créer une politique de la
tension est souvent de la provocation et
au delà de ce dont on a parlé je vais
être très court je m'exprime aussi comme
un parlementaire représentant notre pays
au sein de l'assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan où j'ai beaucoup d'amis turque où
j'ai eu des présidents de commissions
des rapporteurs généraux turcs et jeudi
sous contrôle des collègues qui sont
travaille bien avec les collecteurs qui
sont parfaitement parties prenantes de
l'institution mais là aussi je dirais
que tout ce que j'espère c'est que ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est vrai sur
le plan stratégique puisque c'est notre
sujet du jour ne mettra en péril cette
présence de la turquie au sein de
l'alliance atlantique fait partie des
gens qui pensent que ce serait très
dommage mais il faut quand même faire un
petit peu attention quoi à un moment
donné
vous à vous personnellement mais votre
pays risquent d'arriver aux limites de
l'exercice
et ce serait vraiment dommage parce que
nous ne réduisons pas la turquie ce
grand pays ami à la politique du moment
mais quand même c'est compliqué voilà
merci
pascal allizard oui monsieur le
président merci monsieur l'ambassadeur
président quand il a ouvert la séance
tout à l'heure a dit qu'il s'adresserait
à vous avec amitié et respect je
resterai dans la dans la même ligne même
si les sujets sont sont compliquées
entre nous mon collègue jean marie
bockel parler de son expérience à l'otan
pour ma part je siège à louer c'est eux
et nous avons sur ces sujets là les
mêmes débats et les mêmes difficultés
s'agissant quand même de la situation en
libye
il faut quand même bien reconnaître que
la situation en libye est tout sauf
simple et qui a plusieurs légitimité qui
s'opposent
il y avait quand même le gouvernement de
bengazi
il y avait le gouvernement de tobrouk et
il reste malgré la reconnaissance
internationale
la problématique de la puissance des
tribus et ça c'est pas réglé
et c'est loin de l'être et et vous le
savez très bien puisque ça aussi des
influences sur le sud du pays et sur les
frontières avec l'égypte est
intéressante parler de l'egypte aussi
dans le dans la configuration actuelle
et des tensions qui existent
régulièrement entre l'egypte qui est
aussi un pays ami et la turquie donc
j'aimerais bien vous entendre un petit
peu sur ceux sur ce sujet s'il vous
plaît quel pourrait être votre analyse
de la situation alors oui il ya un
gouvernement qui a été reconnue mais
dont malheureusement la légitimité
d'abord démocratique parce que c'était
quand même pas eux qui avaient gagné les
élections même si les élections ont déjà
quelques années le gouvernement de
tobrouk ce qui est plus ou moins ralliés
mais les gens de bengazi et les tribus
s'est toujours pas le cas donc il faut
bien pouvoir et le président l'a dit à
juste titre la france en fait elle
discute avec tout le monde y compris sur
ce sujet là ça c'était le premier point
est le deuxième point
mais vous l'avez très clairement
développé
c'est quand même la situation sur les
zones économiques exclusives
vous êtes en train d'essayer de sortir
des accords internationaux
alors effectivement on peut toujours
trouver des exemples et vous l'avez fait
d'ailleurs de manière tout à fait habile
et je salue votre habileté en ressortant
cet exemple entre le canada et
saint-pierre-et-miquelon bien évidemment
qu'on trouvera toujours quelques îlots
qui permette d'argumenter sur l'ailé sur
les sujets mais vous savez très bien que
le vrai problème dans la méditerranée
orientale
c'est quand même chypre voilà donc tant
qu'on réglera pas ce problème là on
réglera rien et c'est pas des petits
cailloux
quand j'ai des picaillons mon propos
n'est pas perron de péjoratif et surtout
pas vis-à-vis des habitants de ces
petits cailloux qui sont respectables
comme tout le monde mais mais le vrai
sujet c'est pas ça le vrai sujet c'est
chypre voilà ce que je voulais dire
merci merci pascal alors en visio jean
marc todeschini
merci monsieur le président bonjour à
tous mes collègues chez l'ambassadeur
vous nous avez présenté très longuement
la position de la turquie
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de la défense nous a fourni une
excellente tribune pour défendre le
point de vue d'atlantis se pensent que
les entretiens avec boutons toujours
très agréable vous préparer ça très bien
mais nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
satisfaction la sortie de cette réunion
votre position c'est tout simplement
c'est la théorie j'avais défendu moins
que j'avais ressenti lorsque je suis
allé en turquie avec mon collègue l'a19
prénataux xi et au déjeuner que nous
avons eues avec nous tu très agréable
d'ailleurs c'est tout simplement ce
n'est jamais de la faute de la turquie
et la turquie tirent toujours sur
l'élastique est la déposition
roger à la carte elle se coordonnait la
russie en syrie elle joue la partition
personnelle en libye alors ma question
serais tout simplement tu es ce que vous
pourriez nous dire en quoi
en quoi la turquie respecte-t-elle les
engagements pris en janvier dans le
cadre du processus dit berlin en faveur
d'une solution politique puisque seule
une solution politique peut aboutir en
libye ensuite beaucoup de choses ont été
dites donc dans la discussion vous avez
eu avec le président veut pas revenir
dessus mais j'ai l'impression de tout
pays qui disent la libye comme point
d'entrée pour l'afrique avec une double
approche pénétration économique et
idéologique
vous avez remporté beaucoup de marchés
d'armement en afrique subsaharienne ces
derniers mois vous êtes très présent
tunisie marchés ont procédé marché
d'appel d'offres sur les donne sur le
mot tellement du gaz s'était pas
développée et ça c'est tout à fait
normal dans le cadre du développement et
de démarches et turques mais pouvez-vous
nous apporter des éléments sur l'offre
effectuée en fin de semaine dernière par
une délégation turque officiel via une
entreprise publique pour la gestion du
port de misrata rap qui permettrait bien
succès permettra la turquie d'avoir un
accès direct à la tunisie et si nous
n'avions pas été aussi longs jeux ce
jour les mais revenir sur des
discussions que nous avons eues lors des
déjeuners jorat aborder à nouveau les
conséquences des événements du 20
juillet 2016 mais surtout la suite des
élections municipales
vu d'europe que vous allez me dire que
ce sont encore une fois des médias
français et européens s'ils ne
respectent pas la turquie lui d'europe
ces médias présentent régulièrement une
situation de forte implication des
aiguilles de l'exécutif turquie dont les
affaires juridiques
la question aurait été très direct
peut-être nous aurons une autre réunion
pour en parler
yat-il encore séparation des pouvoirs
exécutif législatif et juridique en tout
petit je vous remercie
merci jean marc jacques le nay oui
monsieur l'ambassadeur
selon le quotidien sabah la turquie a
arrêté quatre de ses ressortissants
soupçonnés d'avoir espionné des milieux
associatifs et religieux pour le compte
de la france
pouvez vous nous apportez la véracité de
ses déclarations et autres points la
turquie abrite dans son sein joyau de
l'architecturé byzantine la basilique
sainte sophie elle elle est aujourd'hui
au coeur d'un débat en turquie certains
font des fondamentalistes turc ne cesse
de réclamer sa conversion aux mosquées
et le président erdogan il semble de
plus en plus favorables si ce projet
venait à aboutir monsieur l'ambassadeur
ne pensez vous pas que la turquie pourra
définitivement tourner la page à
l'héritage d'atatürk celle d'une turquie
moderne et laïque
merci jacques ladislas poniatowski merci
monsieur le président monsieur
l'ambassadeur je suis un parlementaire
français un peu triste de l'évolution de
la turquie et de l'évolution de nos
relations avec la turquie
je vous dis de le connaissons un petit
peu quand même si j'avais fait vous vous
en souvenez avec jean marc todeschini un
rapport sur la turquie qui était un
rapport assez franc qui avait évoqué
vraiment tous les sujets des sujets de
politique intérieure car nous vous
avions mais vu nous avions été sur place
au moment des élections municipales
qu'avait perdue erdogan puisque deux
villes les deux villes les plus
importantes avait basculé
nous avions parlé du problème kurde
nous avions parlé de l'arménie nous
avions parlé des problèmes alors de tout
sauf de la libye si je puis dire
nous avions parlé de la syrie et de ce
qui se passait dans la zone i d'ibm
nous avions parlé de l'évolution de la
turquie au niveau international en
afrique dans le domaine aérien dans le
domaine culturel dans le domaine
islamique et tout ce que vous faisiez et
puisque vous faisiez notamment sur sur
l'immigration qui était d'ailleurs un
des points positifs
autrement dit c'était un rapport qui est
tête
kate est viril qui était je crois
honnête à tout point de vue même s'il
n'était pas tendre soutenez tous les
sujets et quand je vous dis je suis un
parlementaire triste c'est parce que je
souhaite je peux dire que la france est
un grand pays occidental que la turquie
grand pays du proche orient un grand
pays islamique
je crois qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
choses ensemble et en ce moment on n'en
prend pas la direction
je veux simplement allusion à ce qui
s'est passé en mer proche de la libye
on n'en prend pas la direction et je le
regrette
la conclusion de notre apport était
positif on dit on voulait développer les
relations économiques
on avait très clair aussi sur le et ça
ça ne vous avait pas plus sur l'entrée
de la turquie dans la communauté
européenne on vous avait expliqué
pourquoi ça n'était pas possible
selon ce rapport était quand même assez
assez clair et net
mais la conclusion était positive on
voulait développer les relations à tous
points de vue notamment notamment
notamment économiques et ma question
porte sur un seul sujet je quitte la
libye parce qu'on l'avait évoqué aussi à
ce moment là c'est sûr le temps il faut
vous clarifier la position sur l'otan le
secrétaire général de l'otan vient de
décider de lancer une enquête sur la
turquie est sur la position de la
turquie à l'otan cette annonce est donc
il ya quelques jours c'est pas sur la
crise libyenne
c'est sûr mais où est ce que vous êtes
donc où sont vos amis
est ce que vous êtes toujours à côté
notre président a évoqué les missiles
400 il n'y a pas que ce problème là il y
en a d'autres
dans le rapport on n'avait été aussi
très précis sur chypre sur toute la zone
surtout de là alors c'est le seul peut
vous avez évolué un tout petit peu comme
quand vous écoutez de temps en temps
parce que votre discours vous le tenez
pouvait pas faire autrement
vous êtes ambassadeur de votre pays vous
devez défendre la position officielle de
pays j'ai rien appris un camp tout ce
que vous avez dit sur la sur la libye et
sur l'incident avec la frégate courbet
j'ai rien appris vous avez dit ce que
vous deviez direz vous vous êtes là pour
le dire
mais chip vous avez bougé la carte d
aude influence sur lequel la turquie
yves fauré et sur laquelle la grèce veut
ferait vous avez modifié un petit peu
une couleur pas assez à mon goût
il ya des solutions internationales qui
existe il ya d autres hauts il ya des
problèmes difficiles pour les forages
on sait faire les compagnies pétrolières
à faire là aussi vous ne bougez pas
assez je le regrette mais sur le temps
je pense que l' enquête va aller partout
l enquête de l'otan qui va être lancé a
porté sur toute la méditerranée ce que
vous y faites tout ce que vous ne faites
pas va porter sur et bien votre votre
révolution militaire est bon vous pouvez
pas répondre encore aujourd'hui puisque
l'enquêté n'a été annoncée elle va
démarrer on sait pas ce qu'il ya dedans
mais mais bon je vous pose quand même la
question où est ce que vous êtes vous
êtes dedans ou dehors c'est merci aspire
le rang oui monsieur l'ambassadeur
une explication franche et parfois le le
début le commencement de pour lever des
malentendus malheureusement ce que nous
vous nous avez dit sur l'incident
maritime pour commencer par là n'est
absolument pas convaincant puisque en
quelque sorte vous nous vous nous
demandez de nous considérer comme nuls
et non avenus en tout point la version
la version des autorités françaises et
de l'armée française qui est quand même
un peu difficile à avaler à avaler pour
nous je n'ai pas entendu dans votre
propos qu' à aucun moment vous
réaffirmiez votre attachement au respect
de l'embargo et même j'ai crû comprendre
qu en vérité vous justifiez par sa
violation sur une autre aux frontières
la décision actuelle des autorités
turques de elle même ne pas respecter
cet embargo
donc évidemment tout ça nous nous
inquiète et quant au droit maritime
vous intervenez sur cette question
devant nous
comme si la turquie n'avait aucune
responsabilité dans la situation chypre
alors qu'il est reconnu
internationalement que l'occupation du
nord de l'île est au coeur du problème
international qui perdure dans la région
mais l'autre chose que je voudrais
ajouter c'est que je voudrais devant
vous a élevé une protestation contre une
autre guerre c'est celle que vous menez
contre une partie croissante de votre
peuple contre les libertés démocratiques
de notre peuple en turquie même il y a
eu hier de très massives manifestations
des avocats dans les principales villes
de turquie contre un projet de loi qui
est présenté à l'assemblée nationale
turque et qui vise à réduire à rien les
droits de la défense sont turquie alors
qu'il y à déjà des milliers et des
milliers de progressistes turquie sont
dans les prisons il y a eu de nouvelle
vague d'arrestations dans la région
diyarbakir de tout un tas de dirigeants
notamment des dirigeantes des
associations de femmes et de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
il y a eu des actes de torture utilisant
des chiens contre certaines de ces
femmes il y a eu récemment également des
bombardements qui ont visé des
populations civiles à la frontière entre
la turquie la syrie et le nord de l'irak
donc vous comprenez que tous ces
événements auxquels vous opposez contre
tous les témoignages qui existe des
dénégations répétées
évidemment ne contribue pas à ce que
la parole du gouvernement turc eux soit
à mes yeux crédible
merci pierre cédric perrin merci
monsieur le président sur le masa
d'heure moi je reviendrai tout comme mon
collègue jean marie bockel tout à
l'heure je suis également représentant
du sénat le temps chaud rapporteur
général de la commission sécurité et
défense et je tiens à dire également que
je suis parfois peiné pour pas dire
choquée par eric effectivement les
provocations permanentes de vos
représentants dans ces assemblées sur
une progression qui sont regrettables
creek qui créent des incidents avec un
certain nombre de pays alliés qui qui
nous qui nous font de la peine parce que
ce ne sont pas les relations que nous
avions auparavant vraisemblablement avec
avec nos collègues et amis turcs
moi je reviendrai sur un événement qui
doit aucun événement sur des propos qui
sont obtenues et qui ont été tenus hier
par la diplomatie turque à l'égard du
président de la république et c'est un
élu des républicains qui vous parle en
disant que le président macron en s'en
prenant à la turquie ne gagnerait rien
sur le plan interne à la france mais moi
j'aurai rappelé que la france
contrairement à d'autres pays en france
paraît donc contrairement à d'autres
pays la politique étrangère et n'est pas
les positions et les prises de position
en termes de politique étrangère ne sont
pas commandés heureusement par les
conséquences qu'elle pourrait avoir sur
la populaire
la popularité d'un dirigeant
heureusement et la france c'est le pays
des droits de l'homme la france c'est un
pays qui a soif de défendre la liberté
partout et comme le disait le président
tout à l'heure la france est un pays qui
parle avec tout le monde et la france ne
comprend pas les positions belliqueuses
de plus en plus nombreuse
malheureusement de la turquie et la
france n'est pas dans la provocation
mais ça je pense que chacun aujourd'hui
pourra bien voir bien le constater elle
me mène des missions comme ça a été le
cas avec le courbet pour des
organisations internationales et en
l'occurrence pour l'otan mais ce n'est
pas dans la provocation alors comment
est ce que vous entendez pouvoir
commencer une désescalade et quand je
parle de provocation je fait bien sûr
allusion aux différents sujets que vous
avez évoqué d'ailleurs je parle des
activités d'exploitation gazière et
pétrolière à la définition des zones
économiques qui ne sont pas conformes à
la convention de montego bay ou encore
au chantage assez régulier sur les flux
migratoires
est-ce que la désescalade ce ne serait
ce du côté turc en tout cas qu'un qu'une
position internationale qui consisterait
à laisser tout faire à la turquie même
parfois souvent au mépris du droit
international
c'est une question un peu direct mais
malheureusement entre amis on peut se
poser également
enfin je hais guerriau oui président
merci alors que l'opération griffe du
tigre contre les positions du pkk dans
le nord de l'irak semble s'être des
soufflets à ils laissent passer en fait
place à une nouvelle crise humanitaire
la turquie a plus récemment lancé
l'opération serdaigle qui vise
essentiellement des villages kurdes ou
mépris total du droit international de
genève
les populations civiles n'étant pas
épargné par les bombardements comptez
vous faire pour protéger les populations
civiles de vos propres opérations
à l'heure où une nouvelle série syrie
humanitaire apparaît de votre fête en
libye mais je voudrais également poser
une autre question ce sera très rapide
ce 1er juillet 2020 marque le début de
la mise en oeuvre du projet d'annexion
d'israël en cisjordanie
quelle est la position de la turquie
vis-à-vis de ce projet la turquie
serait-elle prête à s'allier avec les
états de la ligue arabe pour soutenir la
palestine
merci voilà monsieur jean macé à une
série de questions particulièrement
ciblés qui appelle de votre part des
réponses
monsieur le président ça me permettra de
revenir quelques aspects que vous avez
eu l'amabilité d'évoquer aussi dans vos
propos introductif et je remercie nos
amis sénateurs sénatrice de poser des
questions en toute franchise nous sommes
là évoqué partager en toute amitié et en
toute franchise
j'essaierai d'aller dans l'ordre dans
l'ordre mais il des fois je peux pas si
je vais dans l'autre c'est monsieur à
l'arc vous avez une question c'est bien
cela le gouvernement d'accord national
n'a pas été élu
ça a été nommée wii un exemple c'est
toujours un exemple le sénateur
on peut j'ai voulu mettre en avant le
fait que nous devons être consistant
dans nos approches on ne peut pas au nom
d'un principe défendre soutenir une
position ici et ailleurs nous en
éloigner parce que ça nous convient le
moins de saint pierre et miquelon dans
un contexte et chypre dans un autre je
crois que madame la sénatrice tout au
début avait posé une question sur
[Musique]
les déclarations de notre ministre des
affaires étrangères hier et elle nous
demandait enfin elle demande s'ils ne
sont pas nous ne soutenons pas le
gouvernement légitime en libye avec des
visées économiques pour des raisons
économiques
bien sûr mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les hommes politiques font
leur déclaration
notre ministre avait déclarations très
nette
hier c'est vrai mais il a fait ces
déclarations en réponse à des
déclarations qui ont été faites à
malberg en allemagne avant donc je crois
et je crois que ça certains de nos amis
sénateurs on remonte à la question oui
il ya eu il ya eu ces déclarations mais
monsieur le sénateur c'était en réponse
à d'autres déclarations qui ont été
faites un jour plus tôt et surtout elles
sont elles étaient aussi inflammatoires
ce n'est que plus quand un ministre des
affaires étrangères voit son pays accusé
voit qu'on a que son pays d'être d'avoir
une responsabilité historique est
criminel c'est quand même lourd c'est
quand même lourd et il faut il faut
qu'il réponde ça je crois que il faut
relativiser les choses
le chère madame c'est la france vous
l'aviez posez votre question ce conte
par vidéoconférence mais vous le
connaissez ce n'est pas ça n'a jamais
été une orientation historique de notre
pays nous n'avons jamais voulu mettre en
avant des considérations économiques
où que ce soit si tel était le cas on
leur ai dit monsieur le sénateur on leur
a dit pas de problème
ça ça et ça aurait été aurait été
annoncée au 6 mai cela étant il est
légitime d'entretenir des relations de
bonnes relations de coopération avec
tout interlocuteur dans ton coin demande
là il n'y a pas de y'a pas de mal à cela
mais de là à qualifier une prise de
position politique uniquement animés par
des considérations économiques
je crois que c'est sous-estimer la
politique étrangère de notre pays
alors monsieur le sénateur bockel je
vous remercie pour votre amitié comme
pour tout le reste de nos amis dans la
salle
notre position dans l'otan nous sommes
notre pays est l'un des piliers de
l'otan et nous en sommes conscients
monsieur le président ce j'avais eu le
plaisir de le dire dans d'autres
contextes avec d'autres amis amis
français je crois que quand on parle de
la turquie dans l'otan on n'est pas
toujours à la hauteur des enjeux
la turquie ça n'est pas ça n'est pas un
pays quelconque dans l'otan et ceux qui
questionnent interpelle la présence sur
le sénateur de la tuerie dans le temps
je les invite à imaginer deux secondes a
imaginé deux secondes l'otan ça la
turquie
à quoi ça ressemblerait et je prétends
je vais aller plus loin est ce que ça
pourrait se maintenir une structure de
sécurité de défense tels que le temps ça
la turquie a je crois que il faut qu on
confesse le pour et le contre des choses
bien sûr de temps en temps il y a des
des questions sur lesquelles ne sont pas
d'accord
monsieur le sénateur nous avons gardé le
flanc est et sud de l'otan pendant la
guerre froide avec beaucoup d'efforts
des fois des fois au détriment de la
prospérité de notre nation notre peuple
je crois que des amis en europe il faut
que ça conscient que c'est eux qui nous
avons soutenues pendant des décennies et
aujourd'hui en cas d'émergence de
moindre hésitation au moindre difficulté
mettre en cause questionner notre
appartenance à l'otan
je crois que c'est un grand tort à votre
ami un allié et c'est pas juste
et je reviens là dessus une fois de plus
imaginez l'otan sa nature qui vous
n'aurez pas d'autant vous n'aurez plus
de temps monsieur le sénateur il n'y
aura plus de temps ça la turquie vous ne
saurez pas traiter l'iran l'irak la
syrie
la méditerranée au sud la caucase la
libye l'egypte tout cela dans une large
mesure ça va ça va échapper quand on
quand on interpelle quand on met un
cause
je ne demande pas je ne dis pas et je ne
suis pas dans cette attente je suis pas
naïve ah ben quoi qu'on fasse qu'on ne
critique pas on est dans le meilleur des
mondes mais pourquoi ces sénateurs
pourtant six amis nous posent des
questions qui nous gêne non c'est pas ça
que je vous dis ça n'est pas ça du tout
que je dis oui il faut qu'on parle il
faut qu'on communique c'est parce qu'il
y à des malentendus c'est parce qu'il ya
des difficultés qu'on dialogue davantage
mais de grâce de la mettre en cause
notre présence dans l'otan je crois que
c'est très osées exagéré ac je ne veux
pas donner de noms mais la turquie n'est
pas un membre de l'otan qui n'a que
quelques centaines de milliers
d'habitations
d'habitants ça c'est des fois vraiment
ça des applications qui nous préoccupe
et je pense que c'est des fois c'est
assez hâtive 1 il faut pas toujours
monsieur allizard oui la libye est
compliqué gouverner de tels pays c'est
pas évident la base tribale ne facilite
pas les choses
mais monsieur le sénateur c'est la
réalité il faut faire avec
il faut dans ces conditions trouver des
solutions politiques adéquates et
c'était l'une des questions de l'un de
nos amis sénateurs
quel est notre vision de solution en
libye mais ça ne peut qu'être une
solution politique sans peut que passer
par une négociation politique et j'ai eu
l'occasion et le plaisir de le dire
devant vous pour que ces négociations
puissent avoir une portée lointaine
durable applicables il faut que la
situation dans le terrain se rééquilibre
et je n'étais pas étonné non c'est parce
que je veux dire mais je m'attendais
quand même que l'un de nos amis
sénateurs disent mais vous vous avez
fait tout ce que vous avez fait nous
sommes pas d'accord mais vous avez fait
une chose quand même vous turc
vous avez rééquilibrer la situation en
libye vous avez rééquilibrer les forces
vous avez empêché la chute du
gouvernement légitime
sans ça ne coûte rien on aurait pu me le
dire mais c'est pas pour autant que je
suis triste mais je ne veux pas être
triste devant devant des amis que je que
j'apprécie et je respecte beaucoup mais
ça c'est infect
monsieur le sénateur c'est la turquie
n'avait pas intervenu aujourd'hui à
tripoli y aurait pas de gouvernement
légitime qu'est ce que ça veut dire par
déduction ça veut dire que on est prêt
avoir un guerrier comme after à tripoli
est-ce que ce qu'on est prêt à cela on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec les
procédures d'accords je ne vous
critiquent pas pour cela mais j'ai quand
même en droit de dire m'écouter si vous
essayez d'imaginer un peu la
contrepartie c'est bien cela qui est
devant nous et haftar vraiment c'est
quand même pas l'individu le plus
démocratique qui pourrait qu'ils
pourraient transférer la libye
aujourd'hui si si il est encore en libye
il a des rumeurs qu'il soit dans un pays
voisin
bah oui à bâle egypte je ne
monsieur le sénateur c'est clair et net
pour pour l'egypte l'egypte soutient
haftar et notre position pour général
haftar et est très net et nous
combattons cette position l'egypte a
pris une initiative vous laisse vous
l'avez suivi une initiative entre
guillemets qui a été prise il ya
quelques jours de cela ils ont daigné
quand même invité
si allah et puis et puis j'ai rapt avait
réuni se sont réunis à au caire on dit
que c'est pour faire avancer la paix ils
n'ont pas daigné appeler flash qui est
quand même le gouvernement légitime dans
le pays
comment voulez vous comment voulez vous
qu'on puisse compter sur une initiative
pareille ça ne peut mener nulle part une
initiative mort née
et là aussi d'autres déclarations pour
nom de notre pays en particulier de
l'egypte je crois qu'ils doivent revoir
leurs cours de mathématiques parce que
moi je me considère comme un diplôme
être réaliste quand je vois certaines
déclarations jeudi mais mathématiquement
ça ne tiennent pas s'en tiennent pas
certaines déclarations qui émane de
certains pays l'egypte ou autre ça n'a
pas dû ça n'a pas d'assise logique
faisable donc de surcroît je ne ne peux
me permettre de ne pas les prendre avec
autant de sérieux
[Musique]
on attend d'eux mais monsieur le
président je suis parti jusqu'à midi un
20e rapport sur l'inde à faire passer de
nana je suis parti jouer plus moi je ne
me plains pas monsieur le président à
votre service une question sur notre
l'aï la monade gens à inverser l'ordre
il est comme ça il me met en difficulté
mais ce pas de problème nous en soirée
difficile de vous met en difficulté
question de madame joël guerriau messier
jouer le diario hoy voilà opérations en
irak ces jours derniers alliance avec
eux des arabes opérations en irak la
tour et la récente opération en irak
s'avise les bases de de paix que vous
savez l'évolution de pékin dans les
années précédentes consiste puisque les
opérations en syrie bouclier de
l'euphrate rameau d'olivier et puis la
toute récente
le bh la source de paix par action sur
te paie a réduit considérablement
l'efficacité enfin dont elle prétendait
en syrie a été a été bousculé et nous
avons mis fin à leur dessein de création
d'une sorte d'état d'état terroriste en
lors de syrie ils ont essayé de
rebasculer dans le théâtre irakien
ils ont essayé de de bouger leurs pions
de la montagne quand deal vert vers le
nord 2
de l'irak dans d'autres villes comme
comme signal comme un standing et sert à
ça on ne va pas y rester indifférents
les opérations précédentes ont eu pour
but de mettre fin à leurs agissements
dans cette perspective et rien d'autre
monsieur perrin une position belliqueuse
wild est critique
je crois que votre question chauveau
chossy une autre puisque il s'agit des
déclarations je vous dis je vous disais
monsieur le sénateur les déclarations
sont faites de part et d'autre et les
déclarations de notre ministre hier
scène ce n'est pas lui qui a initié ce
était par réaction à d'autres
déclarations qui était quand même assez
durs dans notre pays il faut en convenir
le seul sénateur je je je
ça me peine de le répéter mais nous
accuser de de jouer un jeu dangereux en
libye de mettre en péril le contexte
avoir une responsabilité historique et
est criminel ce sont des propos très
très fort et les les propos de notre
ministre ça se situe dans ce contexte et
il répond à ce propos je ne voulais pas
je ne veux pas d
prendre autant davantage comment vous
vous disiez aussi comment procéder à la
désescalade
je crois que simplement je les dis à mon
humble niveau turcs et français ne
doivent doivent plutôt privilégier la
communication directe pas par médias
interposés on n'a pas besoin qu'un
journaliste pose une question pour faire
état de notre attitude envers un ami un
pays ami et allié
je crois que bon mais cela étant je suis
conscient du fait que l'homme politique
il fait ses déclarations d'une manière
souveraine ça c'est autre chose c'est
pas ça que je questionne mais je ne peut
qu'évoquer un souhait devant vous je
crois que nous devons plus nous parler
au lieu de te parler sur nous avec les
autres ou aux médias mettez interposés
monsieur le sénateur perdront je me
souviens durant notre dernière
représentation dans cette salle où si je
n'avais pas pu avoir
comment dirais je ne vais pas pu vous
satisfaire je dois faire encore des
efforts j'en conviens mais je n'ai pas
si vous pensez que j'ai prétendu
exactement l inverse de la dépêche
des autorités françaises mais justement
je pense que mon devoir
notre des voix devoir est aussi de deux
d'élargir les dossiers dans lesquels
nous nous trouvons plutôt au rendez vous
nous sommes sur la même page il faut il
nous appartient à nous de diminuer
c'est ces divergences en chypre monsieur
le sénateur et c'est là que le droit
international parle il ne s'agit pas
d'une occupation
je vous invite à relire s'il vous plaît
l'accord de zurich
deux mille neuf cent soixante dix nous
sommes un pays garants à chypre ne sont
pas un occupant nous avons intervenus
nous avons intervenus monsieur le
sénateur en tant que pays garants on
parle des résolutions vous savez les re
comment les résolutions dans quels
contextes sont conclues négocier c'est
pas pour autant que je mets en cause des
résolutions de l'onu
je sais qu'il ya des résolutions de
l'onu mais il a des résolutions de l'onu
qui est de l'union européenne d'ailleurs
qui invite à ce qu'on mette fin à cette
politique d'isolation pour les jeux
je pris aux turcs on veut ressorte voyez
les résolutions de l'onu c'est un tout
il faut qu'on prenne en considération
en même temps nous n'avons pas mené et
nous n'avons pas l'intention de mener
une guerre contre notre peuple
il y a vous savez monsieur le sénateur
je crois que c'est un dilemme venant des
médias je l'aurais encore mieux compris
mais volant d'un sénateur de votre
niveau
je crois que j'ai le droit de m'attendre
a plus la turquie qu'on le veuille ou
pas c'est un pays démocratique
democratic nous le sénateur la
démocratie ond laforge depuis trois
siècles en europe
quatre siècles il a des démocraties en
angleterre en france en allemagne
mais chaque pays démocratiques à ses
mains n'a pas ses propres règles
démocratiques
mais il y à une version quand même de la
démocratie anglaise française allemande
et c'est reconnaissait la ceinture aussi
leur manière d'exercer cette démocratie
tenant compte de leurs difficultés à la
fois internes et externes
voyez la démocratie n'est pas un modèle
applicable sans aucune adaptation dans
les formes pas dans le fond à la forme
sur le contexte quand même ça je crois
que nous à nous avons assez de pratiquer
ensemble pour que nos amis français
puissent nous reconnaître 7,7
particularité dirigeants des
associations leur demande
ça c'est encore un débat vous savez dans
chaque pays démocratique il a des débats
je ne voudrais pas rappeler à d'autres
débat démocratique dans notre pays
mais c'est normal qu'il ait des débats
que les gens avancent leurs positions on
est on n'est pas toujours d'accord avec
le gouvernement le gouvernement n'est
pas toujours d'accord et dans tout pays
avec certaines certaines émergence au
sein de la de la société quels que
soient les bords mais là il faut le
revoir dans son dans son contexte
quelle est notre position sur l'otan je
crois que je me suis assez haye j'ai
déjà répondu
suffisamment en profondeur à notre
présence à l'otan et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs puisque monsieur
le président m'avait amitié d'en parler
dans ces propos un docu introductif
question de s 400 ça n'est pas parce
qu'il ya le problème de s 400 que là
c'est la position de la turquie au sein
de l'otan et fragiliser davantage mais
s'il vous plaît monsieur le président là
je ne peux pas ne pas le dire quand nos
amis français ou un autre pays
entretient des relations et dialogue
stratégique avec la russie
ça ne pose pas de problème quand les
turcs comme unique et travaille avec luz
alors là il s'éloigne de l'europe ils
fragilisent le temps quand même pas
juste et moi je pense que je pense que
c'est quand même
humblement en tant que quelqu'un qui a
conscience de ses responsabilités
seulement je pense que cette ouverture
de la france est à saluer c'est une
démarche diplomatique considérable mais
là aussi je veux qu'on soit conséquent
le fait d'entretenir des relations avec
la russie qui est une voie
un pays voisin jusqu'à hier encore jeune
et à la géorgie que ne séparent mais on
a des relations des difficultés aussi
ne sois pas d'accord pour ce concerne la
crimée ne sommes pas tout à fait
d'accord en syrie mais ça ne nous
empêche pas de travailler ensemble ne
sont pas d'accord en libye mais pareil
mais il a plein d'autres questions
d'autres dossiers où on n'est pas
d'accord on n'est pas sur la même page
mais ça ne nous empêche pas de pouvoir
travailler ensemble mais sur le sénateur
et monsieur le président je crois que
nous pouvons rester sur ce registre
espionnage monsieur le sénateur si si je
les vitesses est question mes amis
sénateurs on a dit que de toute façon il
faut pas faire autrement quand qu'on
connaissait son passé il n'aurait pas pu
faire faire autrement c'est un personnel
vous avez dire ça mais je vais lui
répondre je vais répondre
à cette question là cette affaire je
sais qu'elle est traitée de près de près
par dgse et le mythe du coup ça date de
2 il ya deux ans de cela que cette
affaire a fait l'objet d' échanges entre
les deux services
le fait que ça a trouvé écho dans la
presse il ya quelques jours de cela ça
n'a aucun rapport avec l'actualité
aucun rapport sauf que semble-t-il un de
ces messieurs
sauf que on n'a pas honoré certaines des
promesses tenues envers l'un de ces
messieurs du groupe noms n'ont pas été
honorées c'est la raison pour laquelle
il était énervé fâché il avait une
déclaration à la presse
l'administration turque
de surcroît les aristos n'ont aucune
implication dans cette partie de la
chose et ça n'a aucun rapport avec
l'actualité monsieur le sénateur je vous
le confirme et je me suis renseigné là
dessus et je vous remercie pour cette
poussette question ça suffit je ne veux
pas l'éviter non plus monsieur le
sénateur à sainte-sophie sahel un moment
donné j'ai lu l'un des édifices les plus
anciens de ne pas très bonnes de
l'humanité après la prise
d'istanbul ça a été transformée en
mosquée après c'est devenu c'est de çà a
été transformée en musée pour il y à il
ya un débat aujourd'hui mais une chose
est vraie musée ou mosquée ça sera
toujours ouvert au public
et là je ne veux pas spéculer là-dessus
il n'y a pas de décision prise
pas de surprise et même si on devait
prendre les autorités turques prendre
une décision ça il faut quand même là le
reconnaître et je suis sûr que nos
autorités sont conscients sont
conscients de la signification et la
valeur symbolique de cette
de cet été vis de qui est si cher un peu
à tous oui serait peut-être ici monsieur
se dessine ici si je ne le souhaitais
pas il serait vexé c'est un grand ami de
notre but est aussi de vous en faire
rapport mais berlin notre engagement est
total
monsieur le sénateur comme nous avons
été présents d'ailleurs à moscou
d'abord et à berlin par la suite on
oublie quand même des voix mesdames et
sénateurs que s'il ya eu un sommet de
berlin
c'est dans une large mesure grâce à nos
efforts mais dans les deux cas d'abord à
moscou puis à berlin
le shakhtar n'était pas au rendez vous
il n'était pas au rendez vous il n'a pas
signé les cessez-le-feu et à moscou ni à
berlin
c'est bien cela qui qui qui nous rend
perplexes comme ça en ps perplexe
monsieur vincent l'âge comment peut-on
compter sur la déclaration de ce
monsieur qui n'a obtenu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui aucune de ses promesses
c'est bien cela pour mr atteint la
gestion du port je ne je n'ai pas
d'information officielle pour vous
prendre là dessus c'est le sénateur et
s'il y avait un accord pour que
les fermetures que gère que le port de
misrata
je ne vois pas en quoi c'est c'est pas
normal puisque aujourd'hui dans le monde
mondialisé il y à il y a il y à des
opérations de cette nature un peu
partout quand quand les chinois gère le
port d'athènes quand la paire française
adp est une autre turc tav gère
l'aéroport dans un pays balkaniques et
ils opèrent ensemble dans des pays
africains
mais vraiment je ne vois pas en quoi ça
aurait été son ré et est il acceptable
l'élection municipale oui c'est
révélateur
ça prouve aussi monsieur le sénateur que
la turquie est un pays démocratique que
l'alternance dans les urnes est possible
et s'effectue de manière régulière
voyez temps des dans les plus grandes
villes de la turquie on a assisté à ce
qu'on a assisté dans les élections
municipales
est-ce que ce que j'ai pu toucher à tout
monsieur le président si en tout cas je
n'ai pas fait exprès si j'ai failli
omettre de répondre à quoi que ce soit
mais pour y pallier monsieur le sénateur
monsieur le président je me permets de
vous inviter vous avez eu l'amabilité de
m'inviter je me permets de vous inviter
pour autour d'une tasse de café ou autre
à aller encore dans le détail dans tout
cela en toute amitié et monsieur le
président je donne redire
je suis très sensible à votre geste il
était très important qu'on puisse
propice échanger et puisqu'il a des
choses qui nous chagrine de part et
d'autre qu'il faut communiquer et
dialoguer davantage et je vous remercie
de m'avoir donné cette occasion monsieur
le président j'espère que j'ai été à la
hauteur des attentes
si ce n'est qu' un petit grain de sel ça
m'aurait rendu heureux s'il ya des
carences j'essaierai d'y pallier
monsieur le président lors d'une même
médaille
chez les actrices lors d'une prochaine
rencontre ici sous ce toit où je me
trouve très à l'aise ou celle où si vous
faites le plaisir l'honneur merci
beaucoup merci merci messieurs merci
d'être venu d'avoir répondu à cette
invitation est bien évidemment vos
explications surmonte apprécié par la
commission vous avez il ressort de cette
audition comme vous l'avez certainement
ressenti une sorte de tristesse je crois
que c'était le mot de ladislas
poniatowski parce que cette relation
entre la france et la turquie nous y
sommes attachés c'est un très grand pays
nous savons très bien
l'influent ce que la turquie exerce dans
cette partie du monde nous voyons la
situation du reste de tous les pays
environnants les crises qui se
multiplient et nous sommes simplement il
ya un peu de déception dans la manière
dont la turquie joue son rôle car nous
nous essayons de jouer notre rôle de
grande puissance demande du conseil de
sécurité en favorisant le dialogue en
essayant de faire de ce faire se réunir
les interlocuteurs et nous nous avons
effectivement le sentiment que la
turquie utilisent si vous me le
permettez la manière forte
que ce soit en mer que ce soit en
expédiant des milices que ce soit en
laissant ou en favorisant l'entrée des
armes même si d'autres le pratique nous
ne sommes pas naïfs monsieur
l'ambassadeur savons bien et nous
n'accusons pas la turquie de tous les
maux dans cette région et tout le monde
n'a pas de tous les bienfaits et les
autres tous les torts ceci posé nous
escomptons que la turquie puisse jouer
justement un rôle de pacification un
rôle de d'intermédiation et non pas de
en quelque sorte souffler sur les
braises si vous voulez c'est un petit
peu cette manière parfois un peu
violente qu'il s'agisse de de la
politique intérieure sur lequel nous
avons droit aussi d'avoir notre jugement
sur la pratique de la démocratie la
pratique des libertés publiques
bon c'est des choses qui nous qui nous
heurte et entre amis on se le dit et
puis
dans moi je sais aussi être
reconnaissant à la turquie d'avoir joué
un rôle sur l'accueil des réfugiés
c'est près 3 millions de réfugiés qui
sont accueillis dans des conditions très
humaine bon mais à chaque fois il ya un
revers à la médaille ce tiers que vous
servez aussi faites pas vous présent
hier de gamme dit attention si vous êtes
méchant avec la turquie
on va ouvrir les vannes et on va lâcher
les va lâcher les réfugiés voyez donc à
chaque fois il ya un comportement que
l'on peut comprendre
et puis il ya des conséquences que que
l'on entre dans laquelle nous ne
retrouvons pas le rôle que nous
souhaiterions voir jouer à la turquie
donc votre rôle d'intermédiation c'est
aussi bien sûr de nous expliquer la
politique vous l'avez fait avec habilité
écarté aussi c'est aussi de faire
remonter
l'inquiétude des parlementaires français
qui reconnaît sur la turquie une grande
puissance régionale qui a le droit de de
faire jouer ses intérêts mais elle doit
le respect le doit le faire dans le
respect du droit international dans le
respect du droit de la mer sur les
affaires de j -p
vous le savez bien il ya des
controverses indiscutablement et des
sujets qui méritait peut-être de faire
avancer les points de vue bon vous nous
dites que des négociations vont
peut-être démarrer entre chypriotes
turcs chypriotes grecs sur la sphère de
la captation des ressources gazières
tant mieux tout ce qui va dans ce sens
cela va dans le bon sens mais au moins
un message que vous pouvez faire passer
c'est faire baisser les tensions les
déclarations intempestives
moi personnellement je ne serai pas
heurté par une rencontre au sommet on a
deux chefs d'état qui pourrait très bien
décider de se voir je pense que c'est
quelque chose auquel oui j'espère mais
si vous voulez ce qu'on voudrait c'est
que dans ses multiples tensions on
puisse prendre en compte les inquiétudes
nous avons des inquiétudes sur le temps
elles ont été exprimées par ce que
puisque jamais le temps connaît des
difficultés on le sait il ya des débats
au sein de l'otan sur le danger qui se
trouve à l'ess où qu'ils se trouvent au
sud il ya le terrorisme qui partout nous
agressent vous en avez été victimes
aussi bon mais cette manière forte qui
consiste à
aller chercher les opposants dans les
pays voisins pour les bombarder c'est
pas franchement notre approche d du
règlement pacifique des problèmes
voilà vous voyez c'est ce sont des
multiples exemples la sphère de
l'incident naval pour les
interprétations je pense qu'elles seront
maintenant dans les écoles militaires et
dans toutes les les revues stratégie
alors on peut en donner une
interprétation nous une autre on
considérait effectivement qu'un bateau
humanitaire escorté trois navires de
guerre qui met en route ces radars de
tir on ne prend pas comme un geste
franchement amical et on peut le
comprendre
après on peut discuter effectivement si
on était en dedans un dans une situation
dangereuse ou pas moi ce que je souhaite
simplement c'est que ces dialogues que
nous poursuivrons poursuivront que nous
le poursuivons avec l'ensemble des
forces en présence la la france essaye
toujours de jouer ce rôle mais que vous
puissiez faire remonter l'inquiétude que
nous avons d'une détérioration très
nette des relations franco turques
depuis quelques mois et qui ne va pas
dans le sens de la paix ni pour vous ni
pour nous je pense qu'on a un autre rôle
à jouer
vous êtes confrontés vous même le
régionalement à un choc entre grandes
puissances que sont l'iran l'arabie
saoudite serra vous avez des luttes
d'influencé qui sont compréhensifs mais
nous attendons de la turquie plus et
mieux en matière de développement de la
paix d'initiative en libye parce que ce
ce pays nous inquiète et vous savez le
rôle que la france joue au sahel
nous savons que c'est par la libye que
s'organise tous les trafics et donc ne
pouvons pas accepter qu'une puissance
quelle qu'elle soit nous le disons aux
russes
j'ai vu tout à l'heure vous avez fait
une petite comparaison quand même un peu
osé entre dialogue avec les russes et
leur acheter des armes c'est tout à fait
différent
on n'achète pas d'armes ou russe c'est
bien connu maintenant ça nous empêche
pas de dialoguer de dire je vous
communiquerai du reste le rapport
excessivement documenté que la
commission viennent signer avec le
conseil de la fédération russe
on identifie les points d accord on se
l'est dit et ça veut pas dire que on
accepte tout de la russie et ils le
savent très bien
on n'accepte pas tout non plus de la
turquie et c'est bien que vous le
fassiez dire maintenant il faut
poursuivre ce dialogue et faire en sorte
que vous qu'êtes l'ambassadeur de ce
pays bien vous nous aidiez à faire
passer ses messages pour faire en sorte
déjà de baisser la tension parce que ses
déclarations intempestives ne font que
aggraver la grave et la relation déjà un
petit peu dégradée et qu'on essaie de
retrouver les voix de la sagesse la
sagesse ottomane bien connus parfois son
expansion aussi mais bon essayons de
trouver des éléments qui nous permettent
de nous reparler que nos chefs d'état se
parlent et qu'ils le fassent savoir
aussi et que les mises affaires
étrangères évidemment ils sont obligés
de réagir en fonction de la situation
voilà monsieur l'ambassadeur merci en
tous les cas d'avoir pris le temps je
crois que c'était une audience qui était
une opposition qui était intéressante
qui était suivie par l'ensemble de nos
collègues
et puis nous espérons que ce dialogue
que vous nous permettez de poursuivre
aboutir à des résultats
c'est ça le rô le modeste mais utile que
le sénat peut jouer parce que nous
allons nous toujours dans le sens nous
parlons à tout le monde et nous nous
prêchons le dialogue la paix les
initiatives qui permettent de ceux de se
parler
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur et puis à
une prochaine fois pour continuer ses
explications et faire le bilan d'une
audition sur l'autre de ski à progresser
et de ski n'a pas progressé
c'est moi qui vous remercie une fois de
plus que ce président et vous avez aussi
combler les carences fait allusion à la
question migratoire aussi tout à fait
d'accord versez de faire sauter tous
merci beaucoup merci à vous voilà pour
cette audition de l'ambassadeur de
turquie en france sans transition on
s'intéresse à un autre sujet brûlant la
5g
quel serait l'impact de cette
technologie sur l'environnement sur
notre santé c'est tout l'objet de la
table ronde organisée par la commission
de l'aménagement du territoire on
regarde cette table ronde on en parle
juste après vous souvenez donc la
semaine dernière nous avons adopté le
rapport de la mission d'information
présidée par patrick chaize sur
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique est aujourd'hui dans le
prolongement de cette table de de ce
rapport nous organisons une table ronde
qui est relative aux impacts sanitaires
et environnementaux de la 5g on
organisera dans la table ronde j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure en en deux
temps une première partie sur l'impact
sanitaire et une deuxième partie sur
l'impact environnemental
cette table ronde elle arrive à un
moment où le sujet est vraiment au coeur
de l'actualité
je rappellerai que les enchères pour les
fréquences 5 g qui devait initialement
se dérouler en avril ont été repoussées
en raison de la crise sanitaire selon le
calendrier fixé par l'arcep les enchères
pourraient ou devraient se tenir au mois
de septembre il y à il ya quelques
semaines deux des grands opérateurs ont
demandé à l'état et à l'arcep de
reporter ces enchères à la fin de
l'année 2020 au début de l'année 2000 21
bouygues telecom que nous avons
auditionné ici même il ya quelques
semaines avancent pour cela deux
arguments qui sont arguments de la crise
économique
et l'argument de la défiance croissante
d'une partie de l'opinion publique
devant sète
le technology en jeu la convention
citoyenne pour le climat s'est également
exprimée en faveur d'un moratoire sur
les enchères et le déploiement de la 5g
quelques jours plus tard la ministre la
transition écologique et solidaire
madame bornes ministre des solidarités
de la santé monsieur véran ont demandé
au premier ministre
l'avis définitif de vente 16 sur les
impacts sanitaires de la 5g pour lancer
les enchères
dernier épisode en date nous avons
appris vendredi dernier que les
ministères de l'économie de la santé de
la transition écologique allait lancer
conjointement une mission visant à
évaluer l'impact environnemental da 5 g
cette mission devrait rendre son rapport
début septembre pour permettre le
lancement des enchères fin septembre
comme comme prévu cette évaluation est
réclamée depuis de nombreux mois par un
certain nombre d'acteurs je rappellerai
que le sénat par l'intermédiaire de son
président a d'ailleurs saisi dès le mois
d'avril
le haut conseil pour le climat pour que
cette évaluation soit menée et à ce
stade nous n'avons pas encore de de
retour donc c'est dans ce contexte que
nous avons décidé d'organiser cette
table ronde qui permettra à l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés d'échanger sur ce
sujet majeur pour nos citoyens
donc pour cette table ronde nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir ce soriano un
habitué des lieux président de l'arcep
monsieur guérin qui est président de la
fédération française des télécoms
monsieur merkel de landes c'est ce
monsieur veille et chef du service de
l'économie numérique à la direction
générale des entreprises
monsieur fair beauf qui va nous
rejoindre qui est le directeur de
projets numériques environnement dans le
groupe de réflexion shift project et
monsieur guérin kharkov qui est
directeur gérant de l'association agir
pour l'environnement qui a formé un
recours contre les textes lançant les
procédures dans les procédures
d'enchères pour à 5 g comme je
l'indiquais donc il y aura deux parties
pour cette table ronde
on va commencer par la partie consacrée
à l'impact sanitaire avec certain nombre
d'interventions puis on ouvrira le débat
sur cette partie là et ensuite on aura
le deuxième partie plus spécifiquement
consacré à l'aspect environnemental et
je laisserais patrick chaize présidé
cette partie de la table ronde sur la la
partie sanitaire je rappellerai qu'en
2018 les ministères chargés de la santé
de l'environnement et de l'économie ont
saisi landes 16 pour conduire une étude
sur les effets sanitaires de cette
nouvelle technologie mobile
un rapport préliminaire recensant les
études scientifiques existantes a été
publié en janvier 2020 le rapport final
devront devant être publié au premier
trimestre 2010 21 les premières
questions s'adresseront donc tout
naturellement allende cesse pour que
vous puissiez d'abord nous nous
présenter les principales conclusions du
rapport préliminaire de 2005 que vous
puissiez nous dire où vous en êtes quant
à l'état d'avancement de vos travaux et
que vous puissiez enfin nous indiquer si
les charges du premier trimestre 2011 21
est confirmée tu as tout de suite la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs merci de nous avoir invités à
présenter l'état des travaux en cours de
l'inde c'est sur l'évaluation des
risques sanitaires liés à la halle à 5 g
tout d'abord je voudrais rappeler que
l'inceste travaille depuis de nombreuses
années depuis la création d'ailleurs des
agences de lave se à l'époque sur la
question de l'exposition à la téléphonie
mobile notamment et les risques
éventuels pour la santé
et donc depuis en particulier
2009l'agence depuis est ce que vous
prétendez mieux se rapprocher peut-être
comment sont enrichis depuis voilà
depuis 2009
l'agent ça quasiment produit un rapport
par an sur la question des risques liés
à l'exposition aux radiofréquences et à
la santé dans divers domaines bien sûr
la téléphonie mobile on en parle
énormément mais aussi les scanners
millimétriques qui peuvent être parfois
utilisés dans les aéroports ou encore la
compatibilité des dispositifs médicaux
exposés à des sources électromagnétiques
ou encore les compteurs communicants
tels le linky qui a fait beaucoup parler
et puis aussi on s'est intéressé à des
populations particulières notamment les
enfants parce que les enfants sont plus
ou moins exposés et représentent une
population plus ou moins un risque face
à l'exposition aux radiofréquences mais
aussi on s'est intéressé à l'exposition
des personnes qui se déclarent
électrohypersensibles et donc vous
l'avez rappelé en janvier 2020 nous
avons donc rendu un rapport préliminaire
qui répond donc qui donne un premier des
premiers éléments de réponse à la
saisine que nous avons reçu en janvier
2019 et la saisine des ministères de la
santé de l'environnement et de
l'économie qui nous demandait de faire
un point sur le l'état des lieux
technologique finalement du déploiement
de la 5g mais aussi sur la question de
l'exposition de la population qu est ce
que le déploiement de la singer va
engendrer comme modification de
l'exposition des personnes au champ
électromagnétique est évidemment de
donner notre avis sur les risques pour
la santé y at il des risques spécifiques
pour la santé liés à l'exposition à la
singer nous avons travaillé avec la mfr
l'agencé nationale des fréquences qui a
rendu en juillet 2019 un rapport
consacré à la description de la
technologie singer pour expliquer
finalement techniquement ce quelles sont
les différences importé par la singer
par rapport au précédent technologies
notamment mobiles et l'anfr a également
publié un rapport ce même mois de
juillet 2019 sur l'exposition des
personnes en se basant sur les
expérimentations réalisées par les
opérateurs
mise en place dans les villes qui ont
accueilli donc ses premières
expérimentations test pour pilote pour
la singer ce rapport a été mise à jour
en avril dernier par l' agence nationale
des fréquences et donc nous avons en
janvier 2020 publié un rapport
préliminaire qui présente en réalité un
certain nombre de d'éléments importants
pour comprendre finalement quelle quelle
différence apporte la 5g notamment en
matière d'effets sur la santé
les deux premières choses qu'il faut je
crois bien comprendre c'est qu'en
réalité en matière d'interaction entre
les champs électromagnétiques et le
vivant il y a une forme de séparation
qui s'opère entre 6 et 10 giga hertz
les choses ne sont pas strictement
binaire n'y a pas une frontière très
marqué mais disons qu'entre six et 10
giga hertz le comportement des ondes
électromagnétiques change vis-à-vis du
vivant en particulier donc jusqu à peu
près 6 à 10 giga hertz les champs
électromagnétiques pénètre de moins en
moins profondément dans le corps et donc
à partir de 7 ans gros de ces fréquences
6 à 10 giga hertz là le l'interaction
des champs magnétiques avec le des
chèques monétique avec le vivant est
essentiellement superficielles les
premiers millimètres de la peau absorbe
en fait les toute l'énergie
véhiculée par les ondes
électromagnétiques donc ça c'est un
changement très important puisque vous
le savez les projets de déploiement de
la 5g sont donc à brève échéance un
déploiement dans la bande 3 5 giga hertz
donc où on a une relative pénétration
des ondes dans un volume dans les tissus
humains et à partir en revanche de 10
giga hertz donc pour la bande 26 giguère
ce qui est prévu pour être déployé un
peu plus tard notamment avec toutes les
tous les objets connectés
on a cette fois une absorption qui est
limité donc à la surface de la peau donc
ça c'est très important à à concevoir ce
qui est du coup nous nous force
finalement à étudier ces deux domaines
un peu séparément alors on a fait le
point donc en janvier sur le nombre
d'études qui sont disponibles pour
évaluer les risques on n'évalue pas les
risques comme ça c'est à partir de rien
il nous faut de la recherche il nous
faut des publications scientifiques et
donc ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
c'est que une situation un peu
contrastée c'est à dire qu'à 26 giguère
si je vais commencer par là à vingt-six
gigahertz
on a finalement un nombre de de données
de publications scientifiques qui est
relativement important donc on va
pouvoir mener une évaluation des risques
et c'est ça qu'on va vendre du coup le
premier trimestre 2021 pour répondre à
la question finalement est ce qu'il y a
ou non des effets sur la santé ce qu'on
identifie aujourd'hui des effets sur la
santé liés à l'exposition aux fréquences
à 26 guerre dans la bande 26 giga et aux
plats et puis la question évidemment que
tout le monde se pose aujourd'hui c'est
qu'en est il des risques pour la santé
liés au déploiement dans la banque 3,5
giguère et là la situation est quand je
vous le dis comme je vous le disais très
contrastée puisque nous avons certes
énormément de données de publications
accumulés depuis très longtemps depuis
plus de 20 ans dans des bandes de
fréquences qui court jusqu'à à peu près
de saint gilles gard c'est à dire
jusqu'à en gros jusqu'au bris fille tout
ce qui est téléphonie mobile 2g et 3g 4g
donc jusqu'à environ 2.5 giguère on a
beaucoup de données par contre c'est
vrai que à 3,5
là on n'a rien tout simplement parce
qu'il ya eu très peu de déploiement dans
cette bande là et donc les laboratoires
de recherche ne se sont pas intéressés
spécifiquement à cette bande là
et les l'interaction des champs
électromagnétiques avec le vivant elle
bouge beaucoup
entre 1 giga hertz de giguère c3
gigahertz on n'a pas tout à fait la même
façon d'interagir entre les ondes et le
vivent donc c'est pour ça qu'on se se
pose évidemment la question
spécifiquement est ce qu'il ya un effet
à 3 5g guerre donc on a assez peu de
données et et ça donc c'est une des
questions
une des trois question qui est posée par
notre groupe d'experts qui a travaillé
sur ce premier rapport préliminaire et
qui question qui est posée aux groupes
de travail qui est en cours d'expertisé
dont on rendra lé résultat donc en début
2021 donc la claque donc la première
question c'est finalement peut-on
évaluer donc les risques pour la santé
liés aux expositions dans la bande 26
guerre donc ça je vous ai dit qu'on va
essayer d'y répondre on a un certain
nombre de données deuxième question est
ce qu'on peut en l'absence d'études
spécifiques sur la bande dans la bande
travail au sein gigahertz
est-ce qu'on peut adapter transposer
extrapoler les données nombreuses
disponible jusqu'à en gros 2.5 giguère à
la banque 3,5 et donc sous quelle avec
quels critères sous quelles conditions
on réalise cette adaptation
donc ça c'est la deuxième question que
la troisième question c'est quand est il
finalement des des expositions des
nouvelles modalités d'exposition
apportée par la 5g
on en parle également beaucoup on va on
va passer d'une situation où finalement
l'exposition était relativement stable
dans l'espace et dans le temps avec les
antennes relais qui qui qui sont fixes à
une situation où des antennes vont
pouvoir focaliser donc les émissions
radio en direction des utilisateurs et
donc on va du coup avoir une variabilité
dans à la fois dans le temps et dans
l'espace des expositions et donc ça sont
des mots de nouvelles modalités
d'exposition qui sont pour nous très
compliquée à appréhender puisqu'il nous
faut forcément beaucoup de données
de nouvelles données de la part des
opérateurs mais aussi de la part des
laboratoires qui étudie toutes ces
choses là pour voir dans quelle mesure
on aura ou pas en fonction des scénarios
de développement de de consommation je
dirais de données est ce qu'on aura ou
pas une augmentation de quel niveau des
expositions pour pour les personnes
voilà en matière de de calendrier
donc comme je voulais dit on va répondre
à ces questions là donc au premier
trimestre 2001 21
pour autant les choses ne seront pas
terminé l'évaluation ne sera pas terminé
avec la singer on aura quelques données
préliminaires les la 5g aura peut-être à
peine commencé à se déployer
on aura typiquement très très peu de
données d'exposition dans un contexte de
déploiement je dirais nominale du réseau
des infrastructures ne concourra pas
forcément répondre à toutes les
questions sur l'exposition à moins de se
lancer dans des scénarios est donc ce
travail est amenée à durer
au fur et à mesure des déploiements et
des informations que nous recueillerons
sur les perspectives de déploiement je
pense notamment aux questions qui nous
étaient posées sur les objets connectés
de quelle façon le déploiement des
objets connectés en particulier dans la
banque 26 guerre va peser sur
l'exposition des personnes dans
l'environnement
ça c'est une des questions qui
évidemment nous serons amenés à à
investiguer plus tard voilà merci
beaucoup
une tournée vers monsieur veille pour
lui demander mais finalement quelle est
la position du gouvernement quant au
calendrier parce que je rappelais tout à
l'heure que l'étude qui va être lancée
sur l'impact environnemental de et
élancée dans un calendrier pour que les
enchères puisse être comme c'était prévu
lancé fin septembre
dans le même temps nous confirme
les études concernant l'impact sanitaire
ne sera connu qu'en début d'année
je rappellerai que la convention
citoyenne avait demandé ou a demandé un
moratoire sur la mise en place de la 5g
et qu'il me semble que le prénom de la
république a dit qu'il faisait siennes
les demandes de la 5g les demande pardon
de la convention citoyenne lapsus
révélateur donc danser dans ces
conditions à laquelle ce quel est le
calendrier du gouvernement
nous aimerions que vous puissiez nous
nous éclairer sur ce point merci
monsieur le président vivement la or le
la secrétaire d'état auprès de bruno le
maire agnès pannier rue nash et la ram a
rappelé hier le plan du gouvernement est
bien de talent et à la tenue des
enchères dans le calendrier qui a été
fixé par l'arcep c'est à dire à la fin
du mois de septembre 2020 est la raison
pour laquelle ce calendrier est maintenu
sais c'est que on reste dans une
approche qui encore une fois et ça a été
soulignée par olivier merkel et une
approche d'examen prudent de l'ensemble
des risques et des facteurs d'enjeux de
la 5g depuis plusieurs années et
d'ailleurs c'est une démarche est là
aussi olivier merkel l'a souligné
kipré date de l'assemblée on est
conscient des enjeux d'exposition du
public aux champs électromagnétiques
bien avant la salle g c'est un sujet sur
lequel d'ailleurs la france un
dispositif qui est bien plus avancé
qu'un certain nombre d'autres pays
et là on le complète pour la 5g donc
effectivement la saisine de la ss date
de
juillet 2018 à peu près qui est la date
de la feuille de route sur sur l'a5 j'ai
donc la proche du gouvernement sur ce
sur ce sujet reste une approche avec
très méthodique des ans des agences
indépendantes chargées de faire des
études que soit l'âge ans des fréquences
landes cesse une approche de dialogue
aussi et c'est extrêmement important sur
ces questions qu'ils soulèvent des
vraies préoccupations qui d'ailleurs
dans certains cas dépasse largement la
5g la préoccupation bien sûr santé la
préoccupation environnementale sur
laquelle on reviendra
la préoccupation de surveillance qui est
très présente dans les inquiétudes qui
se soulève sur la 5g à travers les
objets connectés notamment don qui ce
sont des enjeux qu'il faut qu'il faut
traiter mais pourquoi fait-on la 5g
c'est aussi un élément du dialogue ont
fait la 5g parce que c'est un enjeu de
compétitivité pour l'industrie parce que
il y à des enjeux de capacités sur les
réseaux qui si la 5g arrive trop tard et
là la vague du trafic on l'a vu pendant
la crise du coc vide le l'augmentation
du trafic sur les réseaux mobiles à
terme sans la 5g va créer des
congestions et des congestions en ville
d'ailleurs autant que autant qu'à la
campagne où on a des plots des problèmes
d'accès donc ça ce sont les raisons
fondamentales pour lequel on considère
qu'ils sont toujours à la bhl pour
lesquels on considère qu'il faut faire
la 5g et ensuite ça doit s'accompagner
d'une transparence totale sur les
résultats des enquêtes de l'ansès sur
l'exposition du public on a en france la
chance d'avoir quand même un dispositif
où chacun peut aller demander à avoir
une
une information sur l'ex le niveau
d'exposition aux champs dans un commerce
dans son habitation de manière gratuite
ça n'existe pas partout en europe et
l'enjeu hausse des fréquences fait des
mesures de ce type
très régulièrement et donc il faut
pouvoir donner cette transparence à nos
concitoyens mais il faut aussi pouvoir
se donner les moyens d'être compétitif
particulièrement dans le climat
économique actuel
donc ce sont les paramètres qui sont
pris en compte pour pouvoir amorcer
poursuivre le la préparation de la 5g
sur sur le territoire national qui
aujourd'hui l'orientation du
gouvernement
merci beaucoup monsieur guérin jeu ira
donc vous pourriez vous nous faire un
peu le point sur le regard vous portez
seraient les travaux dans le sas et puis
aussi sur la manière dont vous coopérez
avec landes 16 par rapport à
transmission d'informations puisqu'on a
eu quelques échos une époque que ça
n'était pas toujours aussi fluide est
aussi simple que l'on aurait pu le
souhaiter
les opérateurs qui sont membres de la
fft son sont tout à fait conscients déjà
préliminaire de l'importance du sujet de
l'année 6,6 en débattre je crois qu'il
ya aucun doute dans l'esprit d'aucun
d'aucun des acteurs notre position elle
était elle est assez claire sur la
question de la santé et elle et elle se
retrouve claire et à la technologie et
les technologiques
on constate que la scène j'ai utilisé
une bande de fréquences qui est comprise
entre 3,5 et 3,8 donc est très proche
effectivement des bandes de fréquences
2g 3g 4g et on constate aussi au travers
des expérimentations qu'on mène depuis
maintenant des mois et des mois que
laure leur comportement d'absorption
pour le corps mieux corps humain sont
tout à fait comparables
ce qu'on constate aussi c'est que
on a aujourd'hui plus de quatorze
autorité dans le monde qui se sont
prononcés sur cette question de l'impact
santé et dans des pays comme l'allemagne
l'autriche la finlande la norvège le
danemark l'irlande les pays bas et que
toutes ces autorités ont conclu à la
même chose et il n'y a pas de raison de
remettre en cause les analyses qui ont
été faites notamment dans le cadre de la
4g et il y a lieu de les appliquer à
l'assemblée il n'y a rien de nouveau à
la fois dans les la nature des bandes de
fréquences et puis la façon de les
exploiter il n'y a rien de nouveau qui
justifie qu'on veut remettre en question
les ce qu'on appelle les seuils
d'exposition et c'est ça pour nous le
coeur et la solution ce sont ces fameux
seuil d'exposition
il n'est pas question pour nous de
changer la façon les seuils d'exposition
en question et donc on va les respecter
ces seuils d'exposition depuis des
années démontrent qu'ils sont suffisants
qui sont efficaces pour protéger la
santé on va les respecter
on va les respecter très très clairement
donc maintenant le support et demande à
votre question sur les relations avec
avec lançait sous la mfr votre travail
où on est on est à livre ouvert on est
totalement libre ouvert aujourd'hui on
était dans une phase de démarrage qui
était de l'appel d'offres de chacun des
opérateurs avec des constructeurs où on
a tous intégrés dans nos appels d'offres
des considérations sur la santé le
respect de l'environnement etc
on était dans une phase où le secret des
affaires et est relativement important
il fallait préserver il ya des avantages
concurrentiels
derrière le choix de l'équipementier ces
choix ont été plus ou moins fait pour la
plupart des opérateurs donc depuis avec
les expérimentations qu'on a mené on est
tout à fait ouverts prêts à partager les
résultats de l'expérimentation on l'a
déjà fait on continue à le faire
et puis à rassurer tout le monde sur le
fait que dans le respect des seuils
d'exposition pour nous il n'ya pas plus
qu'il n'ya pas de risque sur la santé
liés à la 5g comme il n'y en a pas liés
à la 4g 3g 2g
on est dans la continuité de
l'exploitation des services précédent
monsieur soriano ce soir yann en donc
pour nous dire peut-être pourquoi vous
avez été très très volontariste sur le
fait que qu'on ne prolonge pas le le
délai prévu pour lancer les enchères en
quoi décaler les lancements des enchères
au début de l'année prochaine même
serait serait préjudiciable
l'argument de ceux qui souhaitent le
prolongement est temps de dire que de
toute manière ce n'est qu'en 2023 que
l'on aura des usages innovants
alors est ce que justement si on décale
les usages innovants seraient eux-mêmes
décalé on a calé votre votre explication
sur ce point et puis une dernière
question un peu un petit peu en marge de
ce qu'on évoque c'est le fait qu'on a
beaucoup entendu de théories
complotistes dans les derniers mois
associant 5g que vides est-ce que sur ce
point
vous avez une idée de la manière dont on
pourrait lutter contre la prolifération
de ces fausses nouvelles qui prennent de
plus en plus d'importance
c'était la question subsidiaire vous
n'aviez pas préparé si si merci monsieur
le président et c'est toujours un
plaisir d'être auditionnés par par le
sénat
et votre commission ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est que la recette n'est pas
volontariste sur le lancement de la 5g
nous avons effectivement voulu faire
notre mû par rapport à cette technologie
je reconnais que ces dernières années
nous avons été je dirais partie prenante
de ce qu'on pourrait appeler un techno
enthousiasme qui est au fond ce qui
apporte l arcep depuis son origine
la promotion des technologies de
communication les meilleurs et depuis le
début de l'année compte tenu de des
appréhensions dans la population
nous avons souhaité opté une posture de
neutralité donc nous ne sommes pas des
enthousiastes particulièrement de la
technologie et je tiens je tiens à le
dire puisque vous avez souligné le mot
de volontaristes alors pourquoi ce
calendrier est bien parce que la 5g est
un projet industriel qui est porté par
des opérateurs qui déploient des
infrastructures et qui ensuite les
commercialise
et nous notre rôle en tant que
régulateur de ce marché c'est de
permettre que les opérateurs puissent
développer des projets industriels dans
une logique de développement économique
est d'apporter à nos concitoyens les
technologies de communication que les
opérateurs je rappelle c'est un marché
qui est porté par des opérateurs privés
apportent les technologies qui leur
paraissent pertinentes donc ça c'est
vraiment la dynamique dans laquelle se
situe la recette vis-à-vis de la 5g donc
dans ce cadre là nous avons défini un
calendrier d'attribution dans le cadre
je rappelle d'un plan national qui a été
défini avec le gouvernement qui
définissait un certain nombre
d'échéances que plan qui a été défini je
crois en juillet 2018 de mémoire qui
prévoyait tout un ensemble de mesures
qui ont été détaillées par par mathieu
veille donc nous avions pris une
décision de lancer cette enchère au mois
d'avril
ça n'a pas pu être possible pour des
raisons techniques puisqu'il fallait que
les opérateurs
con con à dire des échanges techniques
approfondies avec des opérateurs pour
pouvoir préparer ces enchères qu'elle se
passe dans les meilleures conditions et
donc lorsque ces conditions sont revenus
à la normale est bien le décalage
technique qui s'est introduit de ce fait
nous amène à organiser les enchères donc
qu'ils vont commencer entre le 20 et le
30 septembre
mais monsieur le président et ça me
paraît très important lorsque j'ai été
auditionnée au mois de janvier 2015 dans
cette noble assemblée et à l'assemblée
nationale pour ma nomination j'ai
toujours dit que l'arcep serait à
l'écouté des priorités de la nation et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
ça veut dire que nous sommes une
autorité indépendante et donc une
prenons des décisions en indépendance
mais que c'est le pouvoir politique qui
de manière ultime que traduire un
certain nombre de priorités nationales
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
souhaité sur ce recalage du calendrier
de la 5g être à l'écouté du gouvernement
si le gouvernement nous dit que pour des
raisons de priorité nationale
quelle qu'elle soit et c'est aux
politiques de le dire et je n'ai pas en
juger il faut changer le calendrier de
la 5g monsieur le président nous le nous
l'aurions fait et si d'ailleurs le
gouvernement change d'avis monsieur le
président nous le ferons donc nous nous
définissons un calendrier par rapport à
des opportunités industrielles des
opérateurs sur la 5g qui nous paraissent
pertinentes qui nous paraissent
intéressantes
j'y reviendrai un instant sur la
question des usages de l'a5 gestion de
nos permettait mais si pour des raisons
politiques il y a des orientations
différentes qui sont prises par le
les mets hautes autorités de ce pays
nous nous y plierons je crois qu'il faut
pour moi depuis le début depuis cinq ans
et demi je veux vraiment être à l'écouté
de ses priorités en l'occurrence je le
serai encore alors concernant les usages
je voudrais juste dire ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui revient souvent autour
de 7,5 gc mais à quoi ça sert bon et moi
je voudrais juste faire un tout petit
peu d'histoire pour dire que quand la 4g
est arrivé on a entendu la même chose et
quand la 3g arrive et on a entendu la
même chose on avait quand même petit
intuition que la 2g c'était quand même
mieux que le be bop au mais en général
on ne sait pas du tout à quoi vont
servir les technologies au moment où
elle se déploie même l'adsl avant on
était sur notre cv sur la ligne
téléphonique
on faisait internet dialogue chez plus
comment ça se dit en français ça faisait
le petit bolide voilà bon on était très
content c'était bien et quand le haut
débit est arrivé avec l'adsl sedima quoi
ça va servir tout ça vous rendez compte
des méga bits
voilà donc eux et sans vouloir aller
trop loin dans l'histoire on se
rappellera que le téléphone usage du
téléphone était au départ on avait
imaginé le théâtrophone c'est à dire que
le téléphone c'était fait pour écouter
des pièces de théâtre à distance c'est
le sonim usages qu'on avait qu'on avait
imaginé l'eau qu'il faut faut bien se
rappeler que quand on parle de
technologies de communication ce sont
les usages de la société qu'ils
s'approprient ces technologies et de la
technologie a ne fait qu'apporter des
opportunités en l'occurrence la 5g
d'apporter opportunités nouvelles
effectivement parce qu'elle va permettre
qu'ils aient plus de capacités qui parce
que les échanges soient plus rapides
c'est ce qu'on appelle la latence et que
les échanges démultiplie par rapport à
des communications qui seront non
seulement entre des personnes et des
ordinateurs mais demain avec des
capteurs et des censeurs c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'internet des objets donc quel
ce à quoi ça va servir
mesdames et messieurs je n'en sais rien
puisque c'est la société qui va décider
à quoi ça sert donc et c'est toujours la
même histoire
et quelle que soit la révolution
technologique qui arrive en l'occurrence
ben on peut mettre un peu d'eau dans son
vin quand on parle de révolution
technologique de la 5g parce que on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir c'est
quelque chose de très progressif mais
quelles que soient les nouvelles
technologies qui arrive on est toujours
confronté à cet enjeu que à l'instant t
on n'est pas forcément convaincu qu'on a
besoin de nouveaux usages mais lorsque
la technologie arrive
eh bien il ya une appropriation par la
société excusez moi j'étais un peu long
juste pour la théorie du complot
monsieur le président moi je crois que
on est arrivé à un moment où la
technologie occupe une place très
importante dans nos vies et où la
question de l'appropriation de ces
technologies devient un enjeu peut être
aussi important et peut-être même plus
important que des questions
traditionnelles qu'on a tendance à se
poser est donc effectivement peut-être
que sur la 5g si on en a manqué monsieur
le président a passé beaucoup de temps
au sein des pouvoirs publics à se
demander comment organiser l'enchère est
ce qu'il fallait des blocs de telle
taille ou telle taille est immense je
pense que à l'avenir c'est une leçon je
pense qu'il est intéressante faudra
aussi se préoccuper
quand il ya une nouvelle technologie qui
arrive comme ça de pouvoir l'expliquer
et de pouvoir la partager
je crois que il faut aussi que les
pouvoirs publics ne soient pas toujours
dans une logique de pédagogie on dit
toujours que c'est quand on a raté une
politique publique on dit souvent manqué
de pédagogie
mais au delà de la pédagogie je crois
qu'il ya un enjeu d'appropriation et de
partage et peut-être qu'il y a des
choses à faire pour travailler peut-être
sur des modèles différents alternatif
aux opérateurs de regarder un peu du
côté des fréquences libres de côté de
moi de mouvements citoyens qui
pourraient s'approprier davantage cette
technologie est rassuré sur le fait
qu'il s'agit pas d'un plan d'un état ou
d'un plan de grands opérateurs privés
mais simplement d'apporter une
technologie qui sera utile merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président sur le lien technologies
usages aurait pu remonter jusqu'à
l'électricité parce que ça a été la même
chose personne n'imaginait tous que
l'électricité révolutionnera on imaginer
au plus que ça remplacerait la bougie
mais pas mais pas davantage
on va comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
prendre une série de questions donc sur
cet aspect la table ronde sur les
conséquences sanitaires et ensuite on
ira sur la partie environnementale
monsieur chaize voulait intervenir merci
monsieur le président bonjour à toutes
et à tous moi je voudrais effectivement
intervenir peut-être rebondir sur ce que
vient dire sébastien soriano parce que
j'ai pas complètement compris en fait sa
réponse sur le fait que du changement
éventuel du report de deux enchères
puisque c'était la question du président
et je me permet de rebondir dessus
la question était précis c'est à dire
est ce que le report changera quelque
chose ou pas sûr donc la 5g à l'avenir
j'avais eu une deuxième question qui
s'adresse plutôt à guerin et adams est
ce pour savoir effectivement si donc au
niveau des autres pays du monde
on a bien on parle bien de la même chose
on parle bien la même chose à la fois
sur les fréquences sur les fréquences 3
5 et 26 est-ce que donc il ya donc
aujourd'hui des utilisations pour ces
fréquences là mais aussi sur la rupture
technologique que j'appellerais rupture
technologique entre la technologie du
parapluie et puis la technologie du
faisceau dédié
est ce que on parle bien de la même
chose quand on évoque donc les autres
pays du monde et au niveau de la neisse
est au niveau de la fft alors monsieur
soriano premier oui excusez moi si je
n'ai pas répondu effectivement la
question est bien qu'est ce que ça
change de reporter la 5g et bien ça
décale dans le temps l'arrivée de la 5g
jeu c'est difficile de répondre
autrement que ça donc derrière ça il ya
un premier enjeu qui est l'enjeu
classique que nous connaissons et dont
nous discutions ton
dont nous discutons régulièrement dans
cette assemblée qui est l'aménagement du
territoire puisque ça signifie que plus
tardivement on lancera la 5g et plus
tardivement on achèvera la couverture
nationale 2 5g et 4g plus bondés nos
technologies qui vont cohabiter
vous savez que nous avons été en retard
sur la 4g qu'il a fallu un coup de
collier extrêmement important du secteur
qui a fait je le rappelle un bon
d'investissement de 50 % sur ces
dernières années un investissement
annuel du secteur a bondi de 50% en
bonne partie pour la fibre optique mais
aussi en bonne partie pour pour la 4g
nous étions en 2016 le 27e pays sur 28
en couverture 4g
grâce à tous ces efforts qui ont été
réalisés par les opérateurs en 2019
nous sommes 13e et grâce aux assauts new
deal mobile qui a été conclue à
l'initiative du gouvernement et en
particulier de julien de normandie avec
les opérateurs et l'arcep
eh bien j'ai bon espoir que d'ici deux
ans nous serons dans le peloton de tête
de l'europe sur la couverture 4g donc
simplement plus tard nous lançons la 5g
plus tard nous serons en retard dont ce
chantier national d'aménagement du pays
dans cette technologie qu'est la 5g
voilà qui encore une fois aura des
visages différents suivant les
territoires 5 g4g plus vont cohabiter
mais globalement on prend simplement du
retard sur sur un chantier d'équipement
du pays en infrastructures près ya un
volet supplémentaire qui s'ajoute à ça
qui est le volet be too big et le volet
économique on attend de la 5g une
appropriation par les industriels
pourraient tout à fait honnête avec vous
monsieur le sénateur peut pas dire qu'on
assiste aujourd'hui à une ruée vers la
5g de la part des industriels français
bon mais en moins c'est un enjeu de
compétitivité l'allemagne et son tissu
industriel sont très engagés sur la 5g
et il est clair que
quand vous par exemple vous jouez sur la
compétitivité des ports des
infrastructures portuaires
quand vous avez le port de hambourg qui
est dans un sens un projet très avancé
d'internet des objets déjà en 4g demain
en 5 g et que vous avez un certain
nombre de grands acteurs de la
logistique qui se demandent s'ils vont
plutôt aménagée près d'hambourg où près
de dunkerque ou du havre
il est évident que la question de la 5g
entrera en ligne de compte
donc il ya un enjeu de compétitivité qui
voit là ça n'est qu'un exemple parmis
vous monsieur guérin pour répondre à la
question oui on parle bien de la même
chose
le 26 gigahertz et à part cela on parle
de l'appel d'offres qui aura lieu entre
l'as phase de l'appel d'offres qui aura
lieu entre le 20 et 30 septembre c'est
bien sûr les fréquences 3,5 et les
autorités dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
notamment l'allemagne c'est bien ces
bandes de fréquences qui regarde quand
le ms se prononcer elle intègre bien la
bande de fréquence 3 5
on dit qu'il ya pas de problème quand la
commission européenne se prononce avec
cinq avis successifs sur les impacts
santé de la cgl par bien des fréquences
3,5 donc c'est bien de ça dont on parle
il ya plus de douze autorités
aujourd'hui dans le monde qui ont pris
des positions qui sont des agences de
santé qui sont parfois des airs jose de
santé sur le nucléaire et l'ionisation
selon les modes mais toujours des
agences de santé gouvernemental qui ont
pris des positions explicites pour dire
que sur les bandes de fréquences 3,5
il n'y a pas de problème d'impact de
santé si on respecte les seuils
d'émissions
c'est toujours le même débat c'est les
seuils d'émissions c'est pas les
modalités c'est les seuils d'émissions
qui doit être absolument respectée et
c'est la réglementation qui existe
aujourd'hui qui est applicable en france
on respecte c'est cette démission pas de
problème je veux qu'elle voulait
compléter
oui effectivement on a dit
ce matin sur lionel l'a dit il ya une
certain retape en france pour le
déploiement d'un singe et par rapport à
d'autres pays donc on pouvait
effectivement s'attendre à ce qu'on ait
des informations qui proviennent
d'autres pays qui auraient développé
plutôt donc et bien évidemment on a
regardé ces aspects là en réalité les
déploiements ne se perd pas tout à fait
de la même manière qu'en france
typiquement les bandes de fréquences
sont pas forcément les mêmes aux états
unis on a plutôt développé en 26 giga et
pas vraiment dans la vente 3 5
voilà donc il ya finalement on a
certaines difficultés à récupérer des
informations sur les expositions
notamment à l'étranger et pas que pour
ça aussi tout simplement parce que dans
certains pays qui ont commencé à
déployer
finalement il ya peut-être moins de
questions qui se posent et donc du coup
il ya moins eu l'opportunité de réaliser
des études notamment sur l'exposition de
cet art on en connaît quelques unes
il ya effectivement ses positions d'âge
ans qui sont cités par monsieur guérin
bord néanmoins elle s'appuie sur cette
hypothèse qui effectivement tout est
transposable directement
des données qu'on connaît déjà la bande
3 5 ce qui est une hypothèse tout à fait
raisonnable un bien sûr mais que que
l'on va examiner ce que vous entendez
par heure sur tech le pyjama ce que
j'entends pas rupture technologique
c'est que on est sur une technologie
parapluie ce que j'appelle la
technologie parle plus aujourd'hui que
au niveau de la 5g on est plutôt sur une
technologie de faisceaux donc vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure dans votre
propos est ce que là aussi on a des
retours d'expériences d'autres pays je
dirais encore assez peu et c'est
vraiment ça fait partie de toutes ces
données dont on a besoin nous
effectivement et donc du coup d'être
aussi en anticipation donc de construire
des scénarios encore une fois avec
l'aide des opérateurs on aura besoin
d'eux voilà pour pour construire ces
fameux scénario pour imaginer que à
telle échéance on aura tant de personnes
connectées dans un environnement et que
du coup ça produira-t-elle niveaux
d'exposition justement en lien avec ces
fameuses nouvelles technologies
d'antenne qui vont forcément beaucoup
changé la manière dont on est exposé par
rapport à aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le gothard pardon
ouais répond à des questions mais c'est
très intense et très bref c'est pour
répondre à votre question la modulation
du signal est telle qu'elle va être fait
dans la 5g est déjà utilisé par un grand
nombre des technologies aujourd'hui en
france c'est le les boks le wi fi des
box c'est le dvb-t c'est le le dab
c'est la même ville au même type de
modulation c'est le même type d'usagé
monsieur montas oui merci monsieur le
président moi j'étais juste un petit peu
gêné justement entre les différence de
discours entre entre ce que vous venez
de dire les opérateurs et puis le
discours de lanxess ou bombe à connaître
évalué pour protéger connaître on nous
dit que basse on ne sait pas encore
puisque les études sont en cours
évaluer ma l'évaluation vous nous dites
à va se faire au cours du de
désinstallation est pareil on a pas on
n'a pas les retours et donc sur la
protection effectivement on peut du coup
se poser des questions puisque on n'a
pas tout c'est cet ensemble d'éléments
donc c'est vrai quand j'entends les
opérateurs qui disent ben rien de
nouveau il n'y a aucun risque et on peut
y aller je suis pas sûr que ça soit ce
que ça puisse rassurer je pense qu'on a
besoin au contraire de transparence sur
ce sur ce sur ce type de voie là et je
pense qu'il faut peut-être accordé en
tout cas faut un nouveau discours et
j'ai un petit peu l'impression en
entendant que c'est un petit peu comme
si quand on a quand on a travaillé je
suis pas sur la mise en place du tgv
qu'on avait
fait les premiers essais on avait lancé
à 400 kilomètres heures un train sur des
rails pour la première fois mais qu'on
l'avait rempli de passagers et de public
et puis constance dit on va mettre des
capteurs de partout pour voir ce qui se
passe j'ai un peu cette impression là
dans les discours qui sont faits alors
qu'il me semble qu'il faut et que ce que
j'entends aussi c'est que l'urgence
n'est pas forcément n'est pas forcément
là on a eu effectivement oui qui est
venu il ya pas très longtemps qui nous
expliquer qu'il n'y avait pas une
urgence total et est donc j'ai quelques
doutes justement sur 7 sur cet
empressement
voilà merci merci monsieur le gat
on va prendre plusieurs histoires merci
monsieur le président j'ai envie de
m'adresser à mon voisin monsieur
stéphane kerckhove par rapport au milieu
associatif notamment parce que c'est
vrai que le débat sur la 5g est un débat
complexe dans la mesure où ils génèrent
les temps de détention on voit bien les
tensions entre d'une côté d'un côté ce
qu'on pourrait appeler les les promesses
économiques qui sont indéniables qui
vont être un facteur fantastique de
développement mais de l'autre côté
malheureusement des craintes qui sont
fondées ou non d'ailleurs mais qui sont
tout à fait tout à fait naturel et d'où
la nécessité en termes de méthodes d'un
besoin de rassurer l'opinion alors on me
dira il ya toujours dans tout projet il
ya toujours des tensions entre entre les
psychanalystes dirais entre eros d'un
côté et thanatos de l'autre mais comment
dans un monde qui est de plus en plus
complexes et jérôme fourquet le disait
très bien dans son livre vous l'écrivez
très bien dans son livre qui de plus en
plus l'archipel français qui est de plus
en plus en proie parfois à l'irrationnel
quelle est la bonne méthode pour
réassurer alors on avait cru que la
convention pour le citoyenne pour le
climat allait offrir entre guillemets
des perspectives
et puis un petit peu patatras
puisqu'elle propose un moratoire il
semblerait que ce moratoire soit pas
suivi donc comment vous qui est du côté
associatif
comment vous voyez-vous les choses pour
permettre justement à ce qu' une
confiance qui puisse se faire dans dans
ces progrès technologiques
merci je n'ai pas d'autre si madame dos
idrac
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais aller dans le même sens que mon
collègue guillaume gontard houlgate et
qui se sont déjà exprimés effectivement
puisqu'on sait que même madame elisabeth
bornes et a écrit au premier ministre
pour justement demandé un peu plus de 2
je dirais de réponse rassurante haut en
termes de déploiement donc de cette
fameuse 5g et je rebondis sur ce qui
vient sur ce qui a été dit c'est ses
discours un petit peu contradictoire que
l'on entend donc j'entends aussi ce que
dit monsieur soriano c'est que
effectivement qu'elle utilise
aujourd'hui la 5g on s'est posés déjà
ces questions là mais je crois que la
table ronde consiste à savoir si
véritablement il y as opa risques
sanitaires dus certaine manière et c'est
à cette réponse là que nous sommes
sensés plus ou moins répondre puisque
nos citoyens nous attendent là dessus
donc j'aurais aimé avoir un peu plus de
précisions sur cet aspect purement
sanitaire et que vous puissiez peut-être
accordé mieux vous violon merci vient
alors la demande de pardon préville
merci monsieur le président donc je vais
dans le même sens que mes collègues et
parce que je me tiens j'ai un
questionnement par rapport à haubans
d'utiliser donc est-ce que j'ai bien
compris qu aux états unis on utilise une
bande différentes et en europe
visiblement autour de 3,5 4 8 giga hertz
mais est ce que on a mesuré le fait
enfin jeu c'est une question que je me
pose comme ça que s'il ya plus d'objets
connectés
il ya plus de puissance et peut-être
plus d'énergie qui circulera et donc
avec des impacts qu'ils vont être plus
femme
à mon sens plus fort quoi sur sur la
santé
ça me paraît logique mais bon chez la
logique n'est peut-être peut-être pas de
ce côté-là jour bien monsieur chevalier
oui merci monsieur le président merci
aux différents intervenants dans la
la continuité des précédentes
interventions je vais revenir sur la il
a été dit par la fédération française
télécom la queue il y avait rien de
nouveau du côté des sur la question des
seuils d'exposition mais on sait qu'on
va voir avec le déploiement de la 5g une
multiplicité des usages nouveaux donc
avec une beaucoup plus d'interactions
beaucoup plus l'internet des objets ça a
été évoqué donc ça c'est quand même des
éléments nouveaux donc c'est important
que vous puissiez développer sur cette
question d'un particulier
merci la dernière intervention monsieur
ray après on a des références le
président chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs les intervenants merci et de
votre éclairage
moi je pose la question d'une façon
beaucoup plus général quelqu'un fait
allusion aux appréhensions qu'on pouvait
connaître mais sans doute moins
médiatisée à l'époque quand est arrivé
le téléphone la 2g la 3g etc
je crois que nous sommes dans un
il est important qu'on essaie une
approche raisonnée prudente etc
mais j'ai un peu d'inquiétude sur les
sociétés qui n'osent plus prendre de
risques parce que les risques sont
inhérents à la vie et tout les
progression qu'a pu faire l'humanité
depuis des siècles ça a été toujours
avec des prises de risque
nous avons aujourd'hui un encadrement
scientifiques qui permettent de limiter
ces risques
ce que nous n'avions pas par le passé
quoi donc les enjeux toujours le plus le
moins et après voilà autre au delà du
devoir de précaution il ya aussi un
devoir d'innovation
bien on va peut-être demander dans un
premier temps monsieur kerckhove de
répondre à l'interpellation amicale de
monsieur gâtés puis ensuite aux autres
intervenants de répondre à ces besoins
de ces demandes de précisions à défaut
de le demande d'être rassuré merci merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
sénateur de me donner la possibilité
d'intervenir enfin dans cette table
ronde pour tout à fait honnête je suis
un peu sidéré sidéré de la dissonance
il ya quand même un petit grésillement
dans l'oreille entre ce que dit landis s
est lente cesse à raison dit on a peu ou
pas évaluer la bande de fréquence 3,5
3,8
donc on ne ne fera pas dire à londres
c'est ce qu'elle n'a pas dit c'est à
dire elle pose des questions ce qu'on a
dit à de multiples reprises c'est un
rapport socratique je sais que je ne
sais rien très bien c'est honnête
osons l'honnêteté osons la transparence
plutôt que d'interpréter ce que lens s
n'a pas dit on c'est une chose par
contre et ça c'est l' agence nationale
des fréquences qui nous l'a donnée dans
le cadre du comité dialogue de l'agent
voilà pour cette table ronde organisée
par la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire il s'agissait bien de
questionner l'impact potentiel de la 5g
sur notre environnement sur notre santé
dans quelques mois la cinquième
génération des standards pour la
téléphonie mobile doit progressivement
remplacer notre 4g actuelle on sera donc
bien sûr amené en reparler ici au
parlement
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi rester avec nous
l'information politique continue sur
notre antenne
[Musique]